this is Jocko podcast number 385 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening also joining
us tonight Leif Babin good evening life
good evening so recently had Admiral
mcraven on and and we started to touch
on some discussions about
the ethics of War
and this is a very important thing to
discuss this is
this is where we must learn and know
that you have to take the high ground or
The High Ground will take you that's
true on the battlefield and it is
certainly true from an ethical and a
moral perspective
now
the Optics of war from the outside
[Music]
can be absolutely terrible and they can
give the wrong impression and I think a
good example or a good correlation of
that is The Stereotype of military
leadership you know you see the military
leadership stereotype in the movies and
it's filled with these authoritarian
tyrants that yell and scream and bark
orders
and
that kind of leadership in the military
is not normal and it's not successful
when it does take place does it ever
take place yes it does there are tyrants
in the military that yell and scream and
bark orders just like there's tyrants in
the corporate world that yell and scream
Embark orders but it's not normal
it's not it's not normal it's not
successful
leadership in the military is
by people that do the right thing and
listen to their troops and and
care about their people
now when we talk about the ethics of War
look it's same thing there's movies that
present these crazy ethical situations
and
show the military in a bad light but on
top of that there's
there's news media there's social media
there's books out there that
can give a terrible
impression of the American Military and
the ethics in the American Military
that
the American Military is just
unjust and immoral
when the fact of the matter is
that that look that is true there have
been cases obviously it but it is
certainly not acceptable in any sense
the word it's not even remotely common
Americans are incredibly incredibly
ethical on the battlefield
and Americans and we'll talk about this
go through
incredible lengths to protect the
civilian populace to mitigate collateral
damage and to uphold the moral standards
of our country and like I said
we have had horrific incidents in our
history like the mili masker which was
which we covered on podcast 31 why do we
cover the podcast that on the podcast
well because we want people to know
about it
we want people to understand I want
young military leaders to understand
what happens when they don't take The
High Ground
the Sand Creek Massacre
that's another one I did a podcast with
Daryl Cooper on that one
why did I do that because people need to
understand what happens from a
psychological and a peer pressure and a
leadership failure these are the kind of
things that can occur but these type of
incidents are completely atypical for
America and America has an astounding
record
in modern military times
especially when you consider the the
vast amount of war that has been fought
by America
but that being said
since U.S servicemen and women that are
out there doing their job in a squared
away manner doesn't get the clicks
doesn't get the views doesn't get the
lights doesn't get the reads
it's the negative stories that are
written more often
and they're written even though
oftentimes they're completely just
unsubstantiated lies but the headlows
the headlines
that get read those the books that get
sold
that's the way the media works so
talking to life thought it would be a
good idea to come on here and talk about
what it was actually like fighting in
Iraq
talk about the actual Rules of
Engagement
talk about the law of armed con conflict
this way people can hear
the truth about what it was like on the
ground
making decisions leading and how
important it is for the US Military
the entire U.S military from Special
Operations to Conventional general
purpose forces to follow the code of our
country
and which code is that well it's pretty
straightforward
the uniform code of military Justice the
the law that exists within the U.S
military
and this law covers everything
from
drunkenness
to conduct on becoming of an officer to
forgery to robbery and it also goes all
the way to things like kidnapping and
rape and murder and the uniform code of
military Justice generally speaking is
stricter than civilian law and usually
delivers heavier punishments when these
things take place so you have the code
the uniform code of military Justice you
also have
the code of conduct that we follow if
captured by the enemy we covered that on
the podcast with Charlie Plum who had to
live by that code
we also have our
military values you know in the Navy the
Marine Corps we have the values of Honor
courage and commitment
in the army they have the values of
loyalty and Duty and respect and
selfless service and honor and integrity
and personal courage both physical and
moral
so there there are codes that we are
sworn and legally
have to follow
we have to follow these codes and when
you don't follow these codes you get
punished and you get punished severely
now knowing
the moral strain
that is put on men and women in combat
there's a high degree of focus on moral
and ethical training in the US Military
and
that way people have the right morals
and the right ethics to act with to
guide them
and in case that fails during the stress
of combat like I said there are legal
Rules of Engagement that are in place
and reviewed daily to ensure that
service men and women obey the law
because
from a moral standpoint from an ethical
standpoint We As Americans have to take
the high ground or The High Ground will
take us
so
would I miss life anything
yeah I think when you look at the U.S
military I mean just as a student of
History I think that uh I in in my view
I don't know that that there's any other
military in the history of the world
that has gone to such great lakes to try
to minimize collateral damage and
maintain the more High ground and
certainly there are instances as you
mentioned but
um I think when you look at the
comparative history and particularly you
know you see the war in Ukraine right
now with things that the Russians are
doing or other other militaries that
don't share our same sense of of
morality or ethics when you see the
gloves taken off uh there's some
horrible stuff that happens in the
battlefield and and I think the U.S
military goes to tremendous links to do
that
um and uh certainly something I'm I'm
very proud of
so let's start off by reading a lot of
times people throw around Rules of
Engagement
um but I wanted to actually get the
Rules of Engagement that you and I
operated under during the battle of
ramadi and these rules were not specific
to the SEAL Teams they weren't specific
to task unit Bruiser they weren't
specific to Special Operations these
were the Rules of Engagement that
applied to every member of Coalition
forces in the country of Iraq
they very rarely changed
they very rarely changed why did they
barely really change because they didn't
really have to change
they are they are very squared away
and like I said a lot of people hear
about Rules of Engagement but when you
actually read through the Rules of
Engagement
you'll see
and a lot of people think that the Rules
of Engagement are so constraining that
that the troops are put at risk and
while we could identify cases like that
most of the time
that's not a Rules of Engagement issue
it's a leadership issue
and let me just get to it here because
you're gonna see right out of the gate
Rules of Engagement
this is the Roe card
it starts off all caps nothing on this
card prevents you from using necessary
and proportional Force to defend
yourself that's how it opens up that's
the opening nothing on this card
prevents you from using necessary and
proportional Force to defend yourself
so anybody that you hear said well we we
had our hands tied listen can you have
your hands tied when it comes to and
I've heard cases like this hey we
couldn't drop bombs because the Rules of
Engagement didn't allow it yes those
things happen now
I think if if you went back case by case
and reviewed many of those would be a
leadership decision where leaders didn't
say oh
I am willing to take the risk in this
situation to protect my guys therefore
I'm authorizing bombs to be dropped
that that generally is a leadership
issue not a Rules of Engagement
situation but that being said
there has been situations where Rules of
Engagement have have restrained and and
cost lives but as you listen to these
you're going to see it's most likely a
leadership issue then it starts off here
one you may engage the following
individuals based on their contact
conduct a persons who are committing
hostile acts against Coalition forces be
persons who are exhibiting hostile
intent
towards Coalition forces
so hostile intent
hostile intent that means it looks like
someone's going to do something bad a
lot of times you'll hear say we had to
wait until they were shooting at us no
hostile intent they look like they're
gonna do something bad
and then you can engage them
that's that's that's awesome
next one these persons may be engaged
subject to the following instructions a
positive identification is required
prior to engagement PID is a reasonable
certainty that the proposed Target is a
legitimate military Target
if no PID contact your next hire
Commander for decision
so
reasonable certainty
you have a lot of leeway in these rules
it's not overwhelming but to say to a
troop on the ground
Hey listen you need to be reasonable
cert reasonably certain that an
individual has hostile intent and then
you can kill them
that's pretty good leeway that allows
the shooters on the ground to make those
decisions and determine whether they
should engage or not
uh the next one
use graduated measures of force when
time and circumstances permit use the
following degrees of graduated Force
when responding to hostile actor intent
then it goes through the escalation of
force
one shout verbal warnings to Halt two
show your weapon and demonstrate the
intent to use it three block access or
detain four fire warning shot five shoot
to eliminate threat
there's some escalation that you can use
and you and I Leif we've been through
every one of those escalations
and
sometimes you don't have time for these
escalations
sometimes you have time to go from one
to four to five sometimes you have time
to go to one to two to five it things
can escalate quickly but there they are
the the recommendations of
how you can escalate and it literally
says when time and Circumstance permit
doesn't say you have to go through all
these five steps it says when time and
Circumstance permit
so there you go
C do not strike do not Target or strike
anyone who is surrendered or who's out
of combat due to sickness or wounds
check
forward
do not Target or strike hospitals
mosques churches shrines schools museums
national monuments and other historical
and cultural sites civilian populated
areas or buildings unless the enemy is
using them for military purposes or if
necessary for your self-defense
you can see a lot of time and effort
went into these rules of engagement
these are and and you and I reviewed
these many many times on deployment
to make sure that we were following them
correctly and they are well written and
they are certainly
they're certainly squared away for not
only protecting the troops but
protecting as you can see
hospitals mosques churches shrines
civilian populated all those people all
those things
cultural sites
which I remember I went to places in
Iraq where they're like hey this is a
cultural sensitive area you cannot go in
there okay cool we can't go in there got
it
there's also situations where we're
getting shot at from a mosque and it's
like oh we're sending troops in there
gotta get oh sex level approval cool we
got it let's go
so that's that's what happens they put
these rules in place
and these rules have a high element of
decentralized command in them
um
next one do not Target or strike Iraqi
infrastructure public works commercial
communication facilities dams lines of
communication roads highways tunnels
Bridges Railways economic objects
commercial storage facilities pipelines
unless necessary again they're trying to
make sure the troops are protected
unless necessary for self-defense or if
ordered by your commander if you must
fire in these objects fire to disable
and disrupt rather than destroy okay
we're trying to keep the country by rack
infrastructure intact
always minimize incidental this number
this is letter F always minimize
incidental injury loss of life and
collateral damage check
uh the use of force this is number three
going to the next section the use of
force including deadly force is
authorized to protect the following
yourself your unit and other friendly
forces detainees civilians from crimes
that are likely to cause death or
serious bodily harms such as murder or
rape
and Personnel or property designated by
the osc that's the onsene commander when
such actions are necessary to restore
order and security
so these are the situations where you
can
kill bad guys
when they are threatening
your you your unit other friendly forces
they're threatening detainees they're
threatening civilians you can do these
things
and then it says this for in general
warning shots are authorized only when
use of deadly force would be authorized
in that particular situation now why do
they throw that in there
they throw that in there because they
don't want people getting trigger happy
with their warning shots
so you're not going to take a you're not
going to say oh this kid's getting a
little close to me I'm taking a warning
shot they don't want that happening
so therefore warning shots are only
authorized
when you're going to use deadly force if
you're not going to use deadly force
you're not going to fire warning shots
number five treat all civilians and
their property with respect and dignity
do not see seize civilian property
including Vehicles unless the property
presents a security threat when possible
give a receipt to the property's owner
number six you may detain civilians
based upon a reasonable belief that the
person one must be detained for the
purposes of self-defense two is
interfering with Coalition Force Mission
accomplishment three is on the list of
person wanted for questioning arrest or
detention four is or was engaged in
criminal activity or five must be
detained for imperative reasons of
security anyone you detain must be
protected Force up to including deadly
forces authorized to protect detainees
in your custody you must fill out a
detainee apprehension card for every
person you detain
number seven mnci
1 or mncii sorry mnci general order
number one is in effect looting and
taking War trophies are prohibited this
is the only rule in here I don't like
why could we not take War trophies can
you explain this to me Leif why could we
why it couldn't take why I don't have a
freaking Iraqi AK-47 on my wall right
now or at least four of them this is a
bummer it is a bummer that is a bummer I
think when you look back to you know the
uh a samurai sword that you know uh our
grandparents generation you know had in
the Pacific War or a Luger from the
European Battlefield off of a German
officer those things uh you know I
understand why we want to control that
but we could have easily gone through
the demill process to get uh something
uh something that we brought back from
Iraq that is a reminder of who we fought
against and why we fought there
um and uh I think it's it's it's
unfortunate that we couldn't follow a a
a process to demill those weapons and
put them you know put them on the wall
somewhere pass down her grand put
together a protocol next time next War
give the boys the opportunity to take
home some some Iraqi weapons or whatever
all right so now you got a part that I
disagree with
so we should be able to take some level
of War trophies we're going to fight
we're going to war we want to bring back
some freaking War trophies
not you know nothing crazy I mean maybe
a couple things crazy you're not you're
not talking about looting here we're
talking about hey we detained some
terrorists who were shooting yes and uh
we want to they're they're RPG tube that
we can demill and put on the wall and be
like hey this was uh something that we
took from an operation like let's get
that changed next time around they're
Jags the the Judge Advocate General
lawyers for the U.S military let the
troops take some guns home with them do
email them whatever you want to do it's
fine
but let's go all right number eight and
this is the last one all personnel must
report any suspected violations of the
law of War committed by any U.S friendly
or enemy Force notify your chain of
command Judge Advocate CID IG or
chaplain these Roe in effect as of 22
May 05 and these are the ones that we
operated under
so
these rules of engagement that we
operated under
and we did so very strictly and very
completely the reason we we were able to
was number one if you don't follow these
rules you are putting everything at
Jeopardy
everything at Jeopardy
and it's just not worth
not following these rules and no two
these rules are squared away
these rules work these rules make sense
so therefore
utilized these rules
and
that's though that's that's that's the
beauty of these rules they were
effective not just in protecting the
troops but also in protecting civilian
populace and also in protecting the the
infrastructure
they're good to go lay if you were out
there on a daily basis
The Rules of Engagement were good rules
absolutely and I think you know when I I
would I remember hearing from friends of
mine that were were Ford in Iraq or been
in Afghanistan they'd be like I had the
Rules of Engagement are too restrictive
and you know and and as you said that is
a leadership problem The Rules of
Engagement were Broad and allowed us to
do our jobs while protecting the
civilian populace and minimizing
collateral damage and uh following these
rules of engagement you made that
absolutely clear for everybody to ask in
a Bruiser this is a black and white
thing we will follow these rules of
engagement and uh because that's the
moral High ground it's something that we
we were going to do uh because it's
morally and ethically and legally the
right thing to do but also this is
strategically the most important thing
that we could do as well is protect the
civilian populace and one thing that
really stands out to me is you know we
you helped me see that like the Rules of
Engagement gave us everything we need to
actually go out and protect the civilian
populists protect ourselves and actually
Engage The Enemy who is attacking us or
other friendly Coalition forces or
innocent civilians
um uh which which was a common thing
that happened all the time in ramadi
everywhere but
what really stands out to me is I think
about these rules of engagement is
oftentimes I I think what was pretty
common in the SEAL Teams at the time and
friends that were returning from you
know from the Iraq Wars if you ask just
about any steel operator out there like
what was their mission what was their
mission they would say kill bad guys
kill bad guys and I think the thing that
you
helped me see and the rest of everybody
into asking a Bruiser is that that's
actually not our mission our mission is
to secure the populace stabilize the
city of ramadi lower the level of
violence that's what was our mission was
and so does that that meant that we we
were going to have to kill some bad guys
because there were three to five
thousand uh enemy Fighters living
amongst this populace of 400 000 people
in the city of Vermont at the time the
U.S intelligence estimates were three to
five thousand enemy Fighters and uh so
we were likely gonna have to kill some
bad guys but our mission was to protect
the civilians and secure them and and
and ultimately Drive uh the bad guys out
of the city and and uh in the
counter-surgency five that was that was
something that totally uh was a game
changer for us in understanding that
that ultimately our Strategic Mission uh
is is to secure the civilian populace
and so you know every time that you
breathe those Rules of Engagement
um you know to us and told us that that
uh summarizing all of that legal jargon
down and that's that's what got a little
intimidating to people is is all this
legal jargon and we have the the Jag the
military law you're coming to brief us
and give a you know dozens of PowerPoint
slides with all this legal what is what
is a reasonable certainty of Hospital
intent actually mean you know and and I
remember just every operation you
summarizing that by saying if you have
to pull the trigger you better make sure
the person that you're killing is bad
and when you said that it was just
instantly clear to everyone
um that as as long as I can articulate a
reasonable certainty of hustle intent
um that this person was maneuvering in
accordance with a known enemy tactics
you know techniques or procedures and uh
and that that is
um it gave us the support that we needed
to be able to go out and engage the
enemy and protect the civilian populace
um and that that was our ultimate goal
is to secure the civilians build
relationships Within show them that we
were there to actually help them and and
they wanted us there as we met with them
and talked to them to help help them
drive out this Insurgency that was
ruling over them when we got there in
2006 just this brutal reign of terror
and fear that it lived under those three
to five thousand enemy Fighters I mean
just I've often said to people that that
those Jihadi insurgents that we were
fighting in ramadi I think that they are
as evil an enemy as the U.S has ever
faced in our long history and I'm
certainly well aware of some of the of
the horrors of Nazi Germany and Imperial
Japan
um and uh and I think any of those
individuals out there just the torture
and rape and murder and horrible stuff
that they were doing
um you just you you clearly uh you made
it absolutely clear to us that these
rules of engagement will be followed
this is black and white we are here to
help the 400 000 people that are living
here and we're here to live rate them
from this the evils of this Insurgency
yeah case in point when we got there
there had just been a civilian that had
been
skinned alive
and
by by the insurgents when we got there
there had just been a family who had
been the the father had the insurgents
thought he was cooperating with the
civilian populace and they beheaded the
guy and and put his head on the like on
the front lawn of the family these
people were just absolutely
just just heinous in their actions
um so yes I I that now when we got there
was a couple things that I had that was
pretty lucky
um number one
as odd as this may sound I was an
English major in college
and when I was an English major in
college I had to go look at Shakespeare
and I had there'd be words that I didn't
know what they meant and instead of me
if you were before I was an English
major if I saw shakespe Spruce that
didn't make any sense whatever
it sucks
when I went to college and I had to read
literature and I had to analyze it and I
had to figure out what it meant I
learned how to use a dictionary I
learned how to be okay with saying oh I
don't know what that word means or I
don't understand this phrase let me
break it down let me parse it out let me
break down these individual words and
find out their meanings
and so for me if I would have read that
Rules of Engagement
which we just read in 1996 when I was 25
years old I would have been like uh
but having gone to college and studied
English I understood those Rules of
Engagement and I was able to
articulate and explain to the Troops
what they actually meant so I think I
was very lucky in that respect I was
also very lucky and respect that I had
just got back from Iraq and the first
deployment that I did in Iraq was a very
active deployment we were lucky enough
to have a very high op Tempo we were
conducting mission after mission after
mission I got a lot of experience I was
very lucky to be able to do that and
this might sound strange but we did a
lot of direct action missions meaning we
did a lot of the kind of the classic
seal mission of there's a bad guy in
this building in this part of the city
we go out kicking his door grab the guy
capture him bring him back to base
interrogate him go out get another guy
like that's what we did classic seal
mission
especially for the war on Terrace
classic steel Mission and I did so much
of that that
well without a better way of saying this
I I kind of got my fill
and when you do that many missions
you're definitely stoked on it but then
you know my aperture opened up to where
I started looking and saying well what
else could we do what else could we
bring to the battlefield and by the time
we got to ramadi yes I definitely I was
I was looking to conduct those type of
direct action missions but I also
thought to myself how else can we help
so that was already in my mind and look
I know you and Stoner and the rest of
the boys wanted to conduct some direct
action missions no doubt and we
definitely
plan to and did but
I mean it's like uh you know you really
want to have uh chocolate chip cookies
you know well I had eaten a bunch of
chocolate chip cookies the previous
deployment a lot of them and so I was
like hey dude there's steak over here
there's like good burgers over here
there's there's you know uh it's not all
just cracked up it's not all we don't
have to just keep eating these chocolate
chip cookies let's get let's have them
let's definitely have them
but we can do some other things so those
are some things that I was lucky about
lucky that I studied English I hate to
say it it's embarrassing a little bit
lucky that I studied English lucky that
I had done that I had a high Up Tempo in
my previous deployment and I I will I
didn't have any
um
man for lack of a better word I didn't
have anything to prove like I needed to
do a bunch of these missions so I could
be like look what I did and I had a lot
of experience I had a lot of experience
planning and conducting operations so I
was very lucky from that respect
well
first of all I think you studying
English and you've always had a you know
if I've said this before I think if you
have a superpower it's it's taking some
complex things and and simplifying it
down to a to a point where the whole
team could understand it and the front
line troops out there executing can
understand it and it's uh I think that's
something you did a tremendous job of
because the Rules of Engagement require
decentralized command and so not only
for you to actually understand what
those word means what what those words
actually mean all that legal jargon what
does it actually mean
but you you helped me and everybody in
the task unit down to the front line
Troopers understand that so that they
can actually go out and perform their
job and not have to worry about hey can
I take this shot without getting sent to
prison uh or let me ask permission up
three levels of the chain of command and
then by that time the bad guy that was
shooting it uh at you is gone and is
going to go out killing other people
yeah real quick props to our Jag we had
a Judge Advocate General who was working
at Seal Team three and because the
reason I have to bring this up is
because sometime when I was in college I
wouldn't understand something
that this writer had written and I'd
look up the words and I still couldn't
make sense of it so I might talk to our
Jag and say hey what does this actually
mean right here what does this actually
mean put this in some other words for me
so I understand or explain what they're
trying to get across here and then he
would do that and so we had a very
squared away Jag officer
who was was my professor when it comes
to the Roe and what what it means so
that was also beneficial and that and
that enabled you to trust your troops to
go out and execute the mission knowing
that these are the rules we have to
follow the rules it's black and white
and that's how we do things
you know the other thing too your
perspective is
you know you have the Strategic vision
of what was actually driving impact and
what wasn't you know in Iraq and that
experience I think played a massive part
in it I remember as I reported my first
Seal Team uh some Echo and I some of our
good friends were just coming back from
uh from their first Iraq deployment
steel team five and I remember the the
thing that was being said about those
guys was they they saw more combat than
any seal unit since Vietnam which was a
true statement at the time they've done
a ton of operations and then you took
over from those guys and did even more
operations and continued that
um over the course of six full months
and they'd only gotten just a few months
in I think of of doing those kind of uh
capture kill raids and and uh and so you
had a ton of experience coming back from
that that's all the missions that we
wanted to do but you were able to to
able to for me and Seth Stone adult
platoon commander and and for the rest
of task in it to really you know look at
the counterinsurgency manual you know
look at the situation on the ground
um and say hey enemy attacks are
actually up 300 percent here we've we've
been doing capture kill raids for a long
time
um is that actually having the impact
that that we needed to and make that
adjustment and really focus on that our
mission isn't to kill or capture bad
guys and gather intelligence it's
actually to secure those populace uh and
that's how we're going to win this you
know this counter searching fight and I
think you just you really opened our
mind up and I think that was based on
all the experience that you had and the
lessons that you brought back from from
your particular manner to her you know
with Seal Team seven and I think that
was integral to our success in tasking a
Bruiser to really think strategically
about about what is our mission here and
how can we make the most impact yeah
definitely very lucky in that respect I
I was also lucky because I'd been an e
dog I've been an enlisted seal and so I
had done a bunch of deployment says in
the list of Steel and you know what
there was no war going on there's no
more going on when I when I was doing a
bunch of deployments I did a couple like
contingency operations we like the for I
locked and loaded my weapon maybe three
or four times doing shipboardings or
things like that I guess I'd done some
you know a bunch of shipboardings as
well you know so you're I guess if
you're a lock and loading your weapon I
always felt like I was doing something
real right so I had locked in I guess it
was more than four or five times when I
talk about all those vbss operations but
I'd done a bunch of of operations you
know that weren't real even before I got
to Iraq on my first deployment and again
were they were they cool no they were
looking back of course they were lame
but that's what that's what that's what
we're doing at the time I had taught a
bunch of stuff in training cell at Seal
Team one which that is when I feel like
you really learn stuff well is when you
start to teach it
you know you go you go teach Jiu Jitsu
you go Teach an arm lock your arm lock
is going to get better
when you start teaching a heel hook your
heel hook is going to get better because
you have to show the details you have to
figure out why it worked you have to
show these little nuanced parts of the
moves and so I was doing that as an E5
Ezio team one and when I was in Seal
Team One in training cell I was a single
dude and guess what we were doing we I
would go on every trip like nowadays you
know someone will be like a land Warfare
instructor
back in those days if you were willing
you go on that land Warfare trip you go
on that CQC trip you go on that combat
swimmer run that thing we were we taught
everything so I got a bunch of
experience of very lucky to have that
the other way so so I it gave me a very
good tactical sense you know what I had
great people that taught me this stuff
so very very lucky but yeah I mean
there's there's a difference between
training in real world operations right
and there was a ton of people who've
been in training for a long time and
there's some great seals out there and I
think you were in a position as a
platoon Commander to at the Forefront of
conducting these operations just the
efficiency at which you guys were able
to do that and and created the standard
operating procedures for for the entire
SEAL Teams including the sensitive site
exploitation which is gathering
intelligence you guys actually created
that in your platoon on that that uh
deployment so I think those you know you
were coming back from that deployment
and taken over as our tasking and
Commander with more than anybody else
out there and I think that gave us we
were able to harness that to help us
really uh set our our task unit up for
success and focus on where we could have
the most impact strategically remember
when the Army dude came to us in ramadi
and taught us SSE sensitive exploitation
and I was like hey dude like it wasn't
actually me it was my it was my
assistant platoon Commander I was like
hey we need a square way to do this and
we wrote about this in the dichotomy
leadership we need to score a way to do
way to make this happen where this is
not working we need to get it more
streamlined and more more disciplined
and he said okay and he created it and
then we we started doing it and we
started telling other units about it and
so then in ramadi three years later this
the Army shows up and like hey here's
how you're gonna do this I was like wait
and I know we invented it now listen we
didn't 100 invent it because
my assistant platoon Commander reached
out to people that he knew in law
enforcement people that he knew in
federal law enforcement and said hey how
do you guys
like search a Target and they gave him
feedback and he took that and kind of
fitted it to our situation I looked at
it I was like yeah that makes sense and
then we rehearsed it made some more
modifications but yeah those are that
that is an interesting point that we
were able to bring
um but even my first deployment like the
first time we got shot I was like oh
cool I wasn't like I was like oh cool
we're getting shot at it here's what we
do like I wasn't freaked out why because
I'd been
through so much training it's like we
tell that story about Seth the first gun
fight that Seth ever ever got into
ramadi where he was like making
decisions making calls flanking the
enemy and this you know Army Majors like
hey man you must have a lot of urban
combat experience and he's like no this
is my first firefight why because he'd
been through awesome training so I had
done a lot of that the other thing that
was very lucky so that that gave me a
good
tactical level picture but then luckily
I had I was the Admiral's aide and no
one's no one likes to say they were
lucky to be the Admiral's aide but
and I certainly didn't want to go and it
was my commanding officer till team
seven that was like my final mission is
to make you the Admiral's Aid and it was
a smart move for him and I and I look
back and thank him for it it cursed him
at the time but working for Admiral
Maguire
what I got to see was I got to see how
much pressure the seal leadership was
under
I got to see
when we messed up like there was some
drama there was some some negative
negative impacts we had some guys from
Seal Team five they went out they took
pictures and those pictures got uploaded
to some photograph sized Shutterfly yeah
or something and they got seen they got
caught by the press and the Press
published them and it was a bad look it
didn't make the SEAL Teams look good
there was the Seal team seven which I
was at Seal Team seven there was a
prisoner abuse scenario that unfolded
I saw how that impacted the not just the
guys those guys are my friends that got
in trouble some of my guys some of my
friends got in trouble from from other
platoons
and you know so I got to see and think
wow this is terrible if if you do
something like prisoner abuse and the
prison abuse that I'm talking about by
the way is
extremely minor minor to the point that
it's less than a you know a normal steel
platoon new guy hazing that we used to
get that's that's the kind of abuse that
I'm talking about I'm not talking about
torturing people I'm not talking about
uh bamboo shoots under the fingernails
I'm talking about
non-professional treatment of prisoners
is the best way I could I guess I could
describe it so these guys got in trouble
my Bluetooth my sister platoon or other
platoons that still teams haven't
actually got in trouble guys got court
martial guys got letters of reprimand
for their behavior
and I got to see that but not only did I
get to see what it did to the guys I saw
what it did to my boss the Admiral I saw
the scrutiny the key was coming under
I saw him having phone calls and video
conferences with the secretary of the
Navy with the CNO
you think the you think the SEAL Teams
needs the CNO calling asking questions
about what the hell is going on with
this prisoner abuse stuff no
so I saw how that ha what happened to
our community
when guys did things that they shouldn't
have done then I got to see what
happened we all got to see this one but
I got to see it even closer was the Abu
grave Scandal so the Abu grave prison
Scandal again here you have these
soldiers
they're they're not acting
professionally look were they torturing
people in my assessment no they're not
were they were they unprofessional yes
they were
were they electrocuting people no they
weren't were they putting bamboo shoots
on their fingernails no were they water
boarding people no they weren't doing
any of that
they were doing
19 year old idiot stuff that's what they
were doing
and you know what it was a massive
negative impact on the war it was a
massive negative impact on America
it was a it was a massive negative
impact on our image
and our image counts
when you go into a country and your
image is bad the local populace doesn't
trust you and you have to earn that
trust
and did Al Jazeera absolutely and did
the insurgents capitalize on this yes
they did
that Abu ghraib Scandal completely
fueled the Insurgency for three years
you you helped me see that too because I
remember when that when that happened
you know look when when we got you know
there was all this discussion about uh
enhanced interrogation procedures and
you mentioned waterboarding well when we
you know waterboarding was training when
we went through right so only when it's
used on the worst humans on the planet
like uh Khalid Sheikh Mohammed this the
cell professed Mastermind of 911 did it
become this big deal and uh so it Abu
grave to me was kind of like like you
said there wasn't torture going on there
was there was some degrading photos yeah
that's a good word degrading it and uh
and it was certainly unprofessional
um and I was like what's the big deal
people need to just get over this stuff
they're making this giant deal of it you
actually helped me see and I remember
the conversation you had with me and and
Seth about this of like hey this is a
huge deal we just handed a giant Victory
to the Insurgency by these Knuckleheads
doing stupid stuff and these photos are
now being used to recruit the next
generation of al-Qaeda Fighters all over
the world and and that was an eye-oper
for me because my attitude was kind of
like the attitude of I think probably
most SEALS or military personnel that I
know at the time I was like hey they're
overblowing this thing it's not that big
of a deal they actually torture people
you know these these are some of the
insurgents actually The Surge is
actually the insurgents actually be heck
saw off the head of of American citizens
and and and you say you're lucky that I
was there I'm lucky that I got put into
that position working for the Admiral
and I got to sit I mean think about it I
was before we were in a task unit
together I was sitting in a room with
two three four star Admirals in generals
I was sitting in the room with the the
in the Pentagon and hearing how these
things were impacting us otherwise I
would have been the same as you like
dude who cares screw these guys it's no
big deal but no when you see it from a
strategic perspective it has a it has a
huge negative impact
on top of that I'd seen that in 2005
there was uh a sergeant had gone to
trial
and he'd gone to trial for shooting an
Iraqi and killing him
that's not why he went to jail that's
not why he went to jail he went to jail
because he tried to cover it up
so it it was a Justified shot that they
had actually gone in and cleared a
building I don't remember the details of
it right now but I do remember this they
had confiscated a pistol
from that house
and plant taking the pistol that they
had confiscated and planted it on the
guide
and this guy and this is why this
Sergeant got in trouble for doing that
and he had shot and killed uh basically
and please don't quote me on this it was
basically like they cleared the house
they found the pistol they're in there
doing uh you know post sensitive site
exploitation and this guy makes a lunge
for one of the American soldiers and
this guy shot him okay
totally within the Rules of Engagement
and we just went through the Rules of
Engagement is it hostile intent when you
lunge and grab it the weapon of an
American Soldier hell yes it is you get
shot you die
but instead of just calling it and
saying hey this is what happened instead
they took the pistol that they had
confiscated from this guy so this guy's
obviously he's not a no threat they like
shot around into the wall and then put
the pistol in his hand and that's why
they got in trouble
they didn't get in trouble for killing
that guy he he tried to attack an
American soldier at close range so they
shot him that's perfectly legal
but they tried to cover it up
I saw that thing unfold behind the
scenes
and so I had a coming out of being the
Admiral's aide I had a much better
understanding of
the professionalism that was required
and the legal concerns that were
happening and how they impacted
everything they impacted our community
of seals negatively but they also
impacted America and they impacted this
strategic
possibilities of winning this war
so I was very lucky to have had these
experiences and again and I've had
Admiral McGuire on the podcast and
uh
you know no one wants no seal wants that
job no seal wants that job but man did I
learn a lot from seeing these things
take place
that being said when we and not that
being said those are the things that
when we arrived in ramadi it was like
okay
our mission you talked about what our
mission was I'll tell you our actual you
know you said our mission was to secure
the populace The Way We were supposed to
do that and from The Siege sotif which
is the combined joint Special Operations
task force
the the quote that I remember because I
had to say it so many times was to train
and fight company and platoon sized
elements of Iraqi soldiers what does
that mean it means you take Iraqi
soldiers they didn't say Special
Operation soldiers it was just Iraqi
soldiers platoon and company-sized
elements this is between 40 and 150
Iraqi soldiers train them and then fight
them not fight against them but take and
fight them with them alongside them that
was what our mission was
and
where I think the benefit of my previous
deployments and seeing a little bit more
of the big picture and I think really
that big picture you know once you see
one big picture you start looking from
the big picture more often and I think
that's one of the things that led me to
say hey we've we can do DA's and we're
gonna do DA's we're gonna go capture
kill bad guys 100 we're gonna go do
targeted raids
but I think seeing the bigger picture
made me think that
we could do more we could provide more
support and we could do more than just
the the DA's that we had done in the
past
yeah I think that that strategic
perspective that you bought at the table
was was hugely eye-opening for for me
and and for everyone in task in a
Bruiser I think help us focus our
mission because we had trained to do
those direct action missions those
targeted raids or capture kill missions
this was hey get intelligence go out and
grab a bad guy you know interrogate them
go out and grab another bad guy and and
when you looked at you know you helped
me see that hey if we continue to only
do that any enemy attacks are up 300
percent the the and this was Al Qaeda
and Iraq battle space two-thirds of the
city of ramadi this city of 400 000
people was totally controlled by Al
Qaeda in Iraq which is the precursor to
Isis and then and they're Insurgent
allies and and so as we looked at that
it was very clear
that U.S forces weren't winning here and
so we we had to actually really refocus
efforts to uh to to help win
strategically and that meant uh again
securing the populace stabilizing the
city and ultimately lower the level of
violence
um and so you know you were the first
person I ever knew who had read the
counterinsurgency manual what kind of
surgery it meant to me before that was
oh that means non-kinetic operations
which is build you know drilling Wells
or helping people uh
a built build a building you know like a
civil Affairs type operation a
construction project you know winning
hearts and Minds stuff and yet you
helped us really see the
counter-surgency fight this is our part
is that we can go into areas that nobody
else can get into and help secure the
populace in those areas and drive the
insurgents out yeah and we will dig some
wells and we will build some buildings
but in order to do that you have to set
the conditions and setting the
conditions means you need to lower the
level of violence and how do you do that
you kill bad guys
uh the the idea
that we weren't winning
that's a very important concept that not
many people wanted to
actually actually make it's a statement
that not a lot of people actually make
look a lot of at that time 2005 2006
there was definitely people in U.S
government that were saying who were not
winning we're losing were you this is
never going to end it's a quagmire that
was certainly happening but amongst
military people you didn't hear a lot of
hey we're not winning and if you're not
saying you're not winning
that's implying that that you are
winning what I actually heard of was
worse than that though because it was
well we might not be winning but you
know we're not losing
and I would hear that and you're like
what does that actually mean yeah so
then you're in denial about where the
situation actually is so then you can't
take corrective action to fix the
problem so that you are winning yep part
of this and we saw this just unfold in
Afghanistan uh part of this is
the way we fight Wars right now is we
fight it by Replacements now listen in
Vietnam they replaced individuals
meaning you have a platoon life babins
in the Army and he's got a platoon of
soldiers and every two or three days he
gets two or three new soldiers and two
or three of his soldiers leave and so
you're just getting these Replacements
well we realized that that was bad
because now we don't have continuity
within we don't have we don't know each
other they real and they also end up
with guys are like hey I'm just trying
to survive for my year then I'm out of
here I don't care what happens to
anybody else
so then they realized that was bad so
they started taking whole units and
sending them over
the problem with that is you know if I'm
the commanding officer of a battalion
and I do my one year deployment in the
army or my six-month deployment in the
Marine Corps and my boss says hey how
did it go for you what am I going to say
I'm gonna say we won we did this we
proved this we moved we moved in this
neighborhood we took over this thing our
our Iraqi troops got better I want to
say that we are winning
and so when I when you show up leaf and
I say we've got 80 percent of the
populace secured
and you take over from me what are you
going to tell the next boss we are 90
secured what is the next guy going to
say we're 100 security Meanwhile we're
still 30 secured
so this happened where we have people
that are just saying hey we're winning
let's keep doing the same thing over and
over again certainly though the one one
A.D didn't have that attitude their
attitude with with uh General now
General McFarland Colonel McFarland at
the time was we need to do something
different
and I went through this on the on on
some podcasts before of how that
unfolded but yes reading the uh
counterinsurgency manual which I Had A
draft copy of found on the internet A
draft copy of it I don't even know what
triggered me to read it I I mean sure
I'm sure I read something or saw
something you know I had watched the
movie about Algiers what's that movie
called do you know what I'm talking
about Battle of battle for Algiers
you know what movie I'm talking about
yeah I don't remember the name of the
movie them yeah and it's it's an
Insurgency and you can see that they're
losing the French are losing and I just
remember thinking there's got to be this
is what's happening I I made that
connection that this is what's Happening
Here
and France lost and we're gonna lose
if we keep this up
so we you know the the key component and
this is what I had to tell our chain of
command is secure the populace secure
the populace well how do you secure the
populace you go out and you have to work
with the populace you have to get
amongst the populists later on
I think it was General Petraeus that
said we can't win by drive-by counter
Insurgency meaning you can't just drive
by a neighborhood and think now they're
secure you got to go in there you got to
live there you got to set up shop that's
what the one 180 wanted to do
which meant that they were going to be
out and exposing themselves to Danger
going out into enemy controlled
neighborhoods and exposing themselves
doing census operations going and
meeting the local populists going trying
to do these civil Affairs projects that
we're talking about trying to lower the
level of violence how do you lower the
level Vines you go out there and you
find the bad guys and you get rid of
them
so the when the Army in the Marine Corps
had this idea of going into these enemy
controlled neighborhoods setting up
overwatches how do we help them well one
thing I knew we could do is
set up OverWatch positions which I think
am I I think on my first deployment to
Iraq we might have done four overwatches
4 sniper overwatches from fixed
positions
and but they were seemed like it was a
good idea and I I didn't even carry it
through work up in our workup I don't
think we did one sniper OverWatch well I
don't think we did one Urban sniper
OverWatch
did we not one not one but I kind of
remembered we had done this before I
think we could do this again I think
this will be really effective also you
know who did you know who's really into
snipers Colonel David hackworth
so I'm like this this is effective man
we can pull this off
um and for some reason
again luck we had 13 snipers in task
unit Bruiser which is a high number BTF
Tony I think was pretty critical in that
uh and obviously Chris Kyle in that
regard of just making sure that we had
um that we had trained snipers because
they knew how effective that could be
and uh and so I think getting guys ready
we're uh
there was some pre-planning that went
into that to yeah to set us up for
success and the other thing was
going to
Army and Marine Corps Memorial services
and you we went to one of those almost
immediately when we got there
and we continue to go to those Memorial
services
and if you go to one of those services
and you see the the broken hearts
of these soldiers at losing their
friends and if you don't want to do
everything in your power to go and help
them you're not uh you're not a man
you're not an American go into the first
one we went to I had a overwhelming
drive to see what we could do to help
these guys that were out there
patrolling in the day going out there
getting IED getting shot up and what can
we do
to help there was no you know people
talk about oh how do you draw how do you
draw enemy fire you don't need to in
Romani how do you draw enemy fire be all
be alive
be alive and be a coalition forces and
you're going to draw enemy fire that's
what's gonna happen
so
getting our snipers out there
immediately and and you know
in which we did and I know BTF Tony
one of the
most beautiful pieces of timing was BTF
Tony taking a sniper team out to where
up in firecracker which is an area of a
ramadi that was very bad where the
Marines had just had a mass casualty IED
and BTF Tony takes a team up there and
kills an IED in place or two
and I happen to be in the Brigade
tactical operations center as that
report was coming in
and it was like for the first time there
was
some kind of
proactive offense happening and you
could see you could feel it in the room
and I could see it in the in the eyes of
Colonel gronsky you know he looked at me
is is that your guys yes sir that's our
guys and he immediately said to me I
need you over in eastern ramadi like
that's how impactful it was it was so
impactful that within 30 seconds he was
asking me could we put snipers in
Eastern ramadi and I was like yes sir we
can
so when you say Mass casually too I mean
just to just to help everyone understand
what that means we're talking about the
everyone in the vehicle is wiped out the
IED goes off under the vehicle kills
everyone in the vehicle and I remember
talking to Lima Company 38 Marines
awesome group of Warriors that we were
so forced to be able to work with
learned a ton of our tactics from in
their uh their patrol techniques their
their snipers and uh how they set up
OverWatch positions
um but I remember talking about that in
the turret Gunner from that ID was
ejected from the vehicle and it was he
was throwing like several hundred feet
and they couldn't they couldn't find his
body for hours they were looking for it
um and it was just it was just so hard
it was one of the first things that
happened when we got on the ground I'm
hearing these stories and it just yeah
to your point like this just seeing this
awesome group of Warriors those Marines
the soldiers that were out there
whatever we could do to help those guys
and try to mitigate the extreme risk
that they were taking every single day
we were certainly going to do
and one of those things was these these
sniper OverWatch positions setting those
up talk us through just give us like
generically because I want to get into
how you how how you how we how are
snipers what you're seeing what it's
like and then we'll talk about some of
those Rules of Engagement how they came
into play but just talk us through like
a normal
sort of what's the word generic sniper
OverWatch
yeah I think just want to set the stage
about that is we were going into areas
that that had no Coalition forces
presence uh previously and ever and and
uh or certainly not for years at least
and uh when we're going to these areas I
mean the turnover that I got from the
previous seal potato Commander was don't
go into these neighborhoods because
you're all going to get killed and
nobody can even come recover your body
to get you out and so this was an
extremely dangerous neighborhood that
was totally in control of by the
insurgents most of these areas they had
so many IEDs or roadside bombs planted
in the roads that you couldn't drive in
there you couldn't even get into the
areas so
um you know one thing that we realized
we could do is how could we support the
soldiers and Marines how could we
support this counterinsurgency fight how
could we support this mission of
securing the populist stabilizing City
lower level of violence was taken a
small group of you know heavily armed
seals and oftentimes we had Iraqi and
U.S soldiers with us we certainly had
um uh you know Marines with us on on
many occasions as well like Dave Burke
and his uh air Naval gunfire liaison
company but we would we would Patrol
into these areas real quick small group
just for people out there I know you you
think sniper team you think small group
you think two people
to tell me you know a small group in
this case is between
maybe seven or eight on the low end the
low low end minimum force was was eight
seals on our operations usually it was
uh it was anywhere from you know 12 to
14 guys on the minimum side and
particularly when you're going into
South Central money where you know a
hundred enemy Fighters can attack your
position and overrun and kill everybody
this this was not a four-man sneaky
sniper team this was a a lot of times it
was a 30 or 40 Man element that's going
to go in and lock down an entire
three-story apartment building and
you're carrying belt-fed machine guns
and shoulder fired Rockets because we
knew that we had to carry all the
Firepower we would need in order to
defend ourselves from these attacks that
we were absolutely gonna come our way uh
and and I we knew the the soldiers and
Marines would get to us or try to get to
us if they could but oftentimes they may
not be able to just with the ID threat
um and and so we had to be able to to
protect ourselves so we would we would
control and under cover of Darkness we
would park our vehicles and foot patrol
in because that was even at night time
uh I mean those these surgeons were just
waiting to blow blow you up in your
vehicles yeah just to clarify when you
say park your vehicles we'd Park the
vehicles in a forward operating base or
a combat Outpost or the government
center like somewhere it wasn't like we
were just parking them in the street and
going on patrol just just to make sure
everybody knows no this was going to the
nearest Ford operating base that we
could as close as we could get you know
sometimes that was across the canal or
the river
um and then and then we would foot
patrol in
um under cover of darkness when we had
the advantage of night vision and
um and usually things were a little bit
quieter but we're going to areas where
there was I mean the enemy had complete
free reign and total freedom of movement
as we call in the military to do
whatever they wanted to do there was no
one in there to stop them from that and
uh so we we Patrol undercover Darkness
um you know usually that was several
kilometers into enemy territory set up
in in a position if we could set up if
we could set up you know two or three
mutually supporting OverWatch positions
with interlocking fields of fire that's
certainly what we tried to do
um at every chance that that we could do
we'd set up in in get on the rooftops or
get in the the windows of buildings
where we had some uh long axis looks
down down roads uh establish a position
there and particularly in support of
um of U.S army and and Marine operations
where oftentimes we do this as the lead
element on the ground for a giant
operation of a thousand U.S troops and
dozens of tanks and and uh uh you know
engineering Vehicles so we'd go in there
set up these positions
um wait till the sun came up with a call
first called The Prayer would kick off
in the morning kind of uh just before
the sun would come off the city would
start to come alive you'd see insurgents
moving around with weapons
um maneuvering to attack nearby friendly
patrols or setting up for attacks
loading mortars into vehicles and uh and
our Cypress would Engage The the threats
in accordance with the Rules of
Engagement you could see you could
observe hostile acts happening
um and uh or or a reasonable certain
Apostle antennas we saw them loading
mortar tubes and mortars in the back of
a truck obviously that's well within the
Rules of Engagement we know they're
about to go and attack Coalition forces
and so we'd engage them and they would
figure out where we were and they
figured out where we were every time and
they would start to engage us and so
then the tactic that we learned from
three marine sniper teams was instead of
being the sneaky sniper of sniper uh uh
uh mission that would transition from uh
sniper hide to overt fighting position
and so if you were in a large building
you had to have 30 or 40 guys in there
with machine guns with shoulder fired
Rockets so you could actually secure the
buildings and defend yourself but the
thing that we really learned from them
was unless we had an urgent surgical
casually we were whole old in our
position that was an overt fighting
position so now as they started to
attack us the worst thing that we could
do was extract from the building because
uh then then all of a sudden and I
remember a conversation with our
commanding officer was asking me a
question hey why why aren't you leaving
once you're compromised I was like well
sir we're behind concrete walls this is
exactly what the surgeons want us to do
they want to Ambush us out on the street
and so what we would try to do is hold
our position throughout the day and wait
till it was Nightfall until we could
extract more safely under cover of
Darkness with night vision
um you know Etc but it was uh that
became the overt fighting position that
we would utilize and they would attack
us they'd shoot our position they'd
Hammer us with mortars RPG Rockets
machine guns hitting us from multiple
directions and we would engage those
enemy Fighters as they maneuvered on us
and what's hard also for people to
understand is I think and certainly
conversations with our commanding
officer his staff and others was
oftentimes the threat of Friendly Fire
was so significant particularly when we
were out there beyond the Ford line of
advance and we had U.S forces that were
moving into that position well they're
getting shot at by enemy Fighters we
would we would overtly Mark our position
we'd throw a giant blaze orange uh
signal panel over the side of the
building and let everybody know where we
were because the threat of getting shot
at by an Apache gunship overhead with
their 30 millimeter cannon or or tanks
and you know their their tanks and
Bradley finding vehicle soldiers or
Marines in the street would uh the
threat of getting engaged by U.S forces
was so high that we had to we had to let
everybody know where we were and we
would take the insurgents shooting at us
all day long over you know a 120
millimeter main gun round from a from a
U.S Abrams tank so uh that was something
that we often did and there were times
when we ran up the American flag as well
to uh to let people know where we were
um and uh and that was when we felt like
we were in a good defendable position
and the enemy wanted to the enemy wants
to come attack us bring it on this is a
this is a overt fighting position and
the times when I was a part of that was
uh that was my call to raise that flag
up uh it got a lot of attention
certainly and we would get reports from
the the the soldiers and Marines to say
hey the insurgents are coming uh we're
Gathering intelligence that uh they know
where you're at and we'd be like bring
it on we would go we're right where we
want to be but oftentimes that was when
we had friendly patrols out there and uh
we got friendly patrols with Iraqi
forces that are out there trying to
secure the populace and and show a
presence there
um and so I would much rather have those
insurgents attack our defendable
fighting position in an OverWatch
position with the blazed orange signal
panel or the American flag flying to
attack us rather than those patrols that
were out in the street yeah we were
going to win we're going to win those
100 of the time like oh you want you got
30 moves they're gonna uh fight 40 guys
in a in a concrete building with sniper
weapons and like they're gonna lose and
they did
they did uh a couple things that I was
thinking about was
shout out to the Marine Corps Circ boats
because we didn't always drive in
sometimes we were on those boats and
those guys were freaking awesome
outstanding support that we got from
those guys so instead of having to take
a Humvee to a fob go in on those boats
they were they were awesome what an
awesome crew of Marines there and uh and
we didn't have any of our uh typical uh
special boat teams nearby there to help
us to support us but these these marines
uh were awesome and they they took us in
on those surf boats which is kind of a
kind of a a rare but very heavily armed
they were putting it out there hanging
it out there on you know a canal that's
maybe you know 40 or 50 60 yards wide
um and and moving you know moving
through at nighttime undercover Darkness
where you know if you get ambushed man
you're screwed you're in the there's
nowhere to hide nowhere to run and uh
they hung it out there for us dropped us
off quietly enable us to patrol into
those areas of the city without getting
blown up you know Vehicles Frogman
activity right there the thing about
being out at night
um
the the enemy knew that we had night
vision obviously they knew that we had
lasers and they knew they couldn't fight
us at night I would say the number of
enemy that we killed was probably two
percent during the day or sorry during
the night two percent I think you killed
a little guy I mean there's a couple
kills that were at night that were kind
of chance contacts but the enemy knew
that we owned the night and so they
didn't come out at night the local
populace had no reason to be out at
night so they didn't come out at night
but the local pompees came out during
the day and that's when the insurgents
would come out as well that's why
discretion was so important and not just
this civilian so you had civilians out
there
you have Iraqi soldiers out there you
have Americans out there the the amount
of discipline that the snipers had to
have and the Machine Gunners had to have
was incredible and I remember
uh so you have Iraqi soldiers out there
I remember the first time you know a guy
came running around the corner with a
with an RPG on in his hand and RPG
rounds on his back and for my entire
life
to me RPG meant enemy kill this guy and
he goes running by and then I see like
it's a bunch of Iraqi soldiers like this
so the PID is even harder because you
got Iraqi soldiers out there that are
carrying k-47s just like the insurgents
and on top of all this the insurgents
had captured American uniforms they had
matching uniforms with the Iraqi
soldiers because the Iraqi soldiers were
wearing kind of mix match cammies
they had helmets the insurgents had
helmets the insurgents had body armor
the insurgents had AK-47s
so they looked like
the Iraqi soldiers they had RPGs
so that idea of
hostile intent
had to be hammered home because if you
just shoot a guy with an AK-47 you might
have just killed an Iraqi soldier if you
just shoot a guy with an a with a RPG
you might have just killed an Iraqi
soldier
if you just shoot a person that you see
walking down the street you might have
just killed a civilian so the the
discretion had to be absolutely massive
and we learned that the hard way
because
as as we as I wrote about an extreme
ownership the first chapter we had one
of our guys
kill an Iraqi soldier
and I go through the circumstances in
the book
of how it specifically happened but but
I had to make sure therefore we had to
make sure that that didn't happen again
so PID positive identification was
front and center of every single
person's mind
front center of every person's mind so
this is why it was such a a critical
component
um and you know you talked about like
the there were some there were some even
even inside the seal Community some
people are like oh these guys and Tu
bruis are just rolling out on these
daytime presence Patrols
we didn't do a lot of presence patrols
of actual process patrols I think you
you knew the number it was 14. we think
it was 14. so out of hundreds of
operations we probably did a 100 you
know missions we did 14 presidents
Patrols in the day they were dangerous
as hell that's why we didn't do a bunch
of them they were very dangerous we
never we got in some contacts we never
took casualty
but
the reason was it wasn't a great job for
us we did it sometimes
but what we did do was combat advising
of the Iraqi clearance forces that were
on the ground in the daytime and we
would put seals with those Iraqi forces
so we might have four or five seals on
the ground with the clearance operation
so you've got a clearance operation that
might have 20 or 50 or 100 Iraqi
soldiers we'd put seals with them the
seals with them are doing actual combat
advising they're doing commanding
control for them
there's probably 20 or 30 American
soldiers so there's deconfliction going
on as well
and what they're doing is they're going
house to house doing clearance meeting
the locals
getting building relationships with the
people like you said life there's 400
000 civilians there
and if there wasn't 400 000 there was
three hundred thousand so this place is
crawling with locals crawling with
locals
and so taking that partner Force into
the local neighborhoods to meet to find
out what's happening to find out to
gather intelligence to let them know
that we were coming to let them know
that we were here
and the enemy would attack yes and
that's why this this one-two punch of
having a clearance operation happening
with Iraqi soldiers American soldiers
maybe some seals in the C2 element on
the ground and then these sniper
OverWatch teams sometimes bounding
sniper OverWatch teams that's another
thing that we did but sometimes in fixed
positions
engaging targets when these gun fights
would break out
and the other thing oh God obviously
going to say real quick about the one is
that you're 100 right I mean this as the
day would you know we're in an OverWatch
position as daylight you know uh breaks
uh and the city Comes Alive there's
people out there just trying to live
their lives and you see the shepherd
boys bringing his herd of sheep down to
the river to you know water water the
sheep and you'd see people working on
cars and and Vehicles driving around and
and you know there wasn't there wasn't a
lot of Commerce to them because they
certainly uh there was there was these
people lived in a war zone uh but yeah
there were people out there so you had
to the cybers had to be extremely
scrutinizing and and uh positive
identification was absolutely key in
every aspect
um the other thing about about those the
patrols was you know people are like
it's crazy you guys are out there
patrolling the contact well there was a
real counter-insurgency reason for that
and now as you you said like we we can't
do drive-by counterinsurgency as General
Petraeus said later you you actually
have to engage with the populace our
mission was to train and fight platoon
and Company size units of Iraqi soldiers
and that was getting those Iraqi
soldiers out there to show them that
they could actually show the populace
that we're here uh was was that was
absolutely in our mission I think we you
know it was dangerous but we did the
best we could to mitigate the risk we
can control we set sniper over watches
in place uh in just about every case
that we have patrols going on or we had
bounding overwatches as you said of you
know a cover and moving for each other
one unit's covering while the other is
patrolling uh and oftentimes what most
of our sniper overwatches were was
covering for the military transition
teams the U.S soldiers and marines that
were out there with the Iraqi soldiers
as well as the regular conventional U.S
army and Marine units that were engaging
out there engaging with the populist
meeting with them when I say engaging
they're out there knocking on doors
talking to people saying hey where can
we help uh you know where are the
insurgents what can we do to help you
we're here to help and protect you with
the Iraqi Soldiers with them uh and
obviously that was a huge piece their
counter-surgency and we did that in
order to support that effort trying to
mitigate the risks that we can control
in that effort yeah the census
operations the the hearts and Minds
campaign totally critical and luckily
when a when the when the shooting starts
the women the children the innocent men
they hide they're not they're not
they're walking around this isn't like
you're sitting there saying oh well is
this person bad or good this person's
running across the street with an AK-47
they're getting shot by U.S forces
that's what's happening they're not oh a
woman walking down the street during a
gun fight oh I wonder if she's good or
bad that's not happening it's not
happening
just like you don't have a woman walking
down the street during a gunfight an
innocent woman's not walking down the
street during a gunfight that was
actually one of the most Eerie things
and I love the the one of the pictures
that we've used uh I don't know what
chapter we used it for in extreme
ownership but it's a it's a picture of
task unit Bruiser seals to the left and
right side of a street kind of a you
know going down this Narrow Street with
walls on both sides and you're looking
down the street empty it's a city street
and it's totally empty and you knew it
was it was it was amazing how the locals
know what's coming they see you know
they can see down the side streets they
get the word all of a sudden you'd be on
patrol there's people moving around
um there's there's a family there's kids
checking a soccer ball there's cars in
the street and all of a sudden it's just
empty and you know okay attacks coming
set your stopwatch you know what's
coming now now all of a sudden the hair
on the back of your necks is standing
out because you know that you're about
to get attacked so so the locals would
disappear which is also why you know you
read The Rules of Engagement and in that
escalation of Force if if you've got
someone who's maneuvering against you
and you're pointing a weapon at them and
shouting at them to stay back and you've
got an interpreter telling them in
Arabic to stay back
well they're going to move I mean an
innocent person is going to run they're
they're gonna they're gonna like oh man
someone's point of God at me I need to
back off which they did it was no no
problem if if they were to to venture
out
um and then obviously if they continue
towards you if if it became a
threatening situation you could utilize
a warning shot to let them know like hey
you need to back off and they would so
so the idea like we were able to uh to
use those Rules of Engagement to
absolutely minimize you know any kind of
collateral damage because they were uh
the people would disappear uh number one
before an attack happened in most cases
uh and in other cases if you've got
someone that's it's a question you don't
see a weapon but you're not sure why
they're maneuvering towards you you
would use that escalation uh and and
look if someone's going to continue
toward your position after they uh have
been told to back off and that they have
a weapon pointed at them and then they
get closer and they get a warning shot
fired in the street 20 feet in front of
them
I mean they're they're bad there's no
question that they're bad if they're
they're maneuvering in your position
um and so that that uh that was the
Rules of Engagement gave us everything
that we needed to do to to protect
innocent civilians uh in that regard and
and protect ourselves yeah and
it was also easy to you know like uh
I've heard people like oh you can't just
shoot people with cell phones right well
there was no cell phones in in ramadi
there was no there was no self the
al-Qaeda had blown up all the cell
towers they didn't want any cell phones
to be there to be used by for tracking
so they blew up all the cell all the
cell towers so there's no cell phones so
when you saw someone communicating
they're communicating on a on a radio on
a on a high frequency or a very high
frequency or ultra high frequency radio
a Motorola radio and guess what they
were doing they weren't ordering pizza
they were coordinating attacks so that's
a totally different thing and again you
don't see innocent women out
communicating on a Motorola radio on a
handheld radio
because they're innocent no there's
military aged male with radios with
radio out there passing intelligence and
coordinating attacks that's what's
happening so this idea that there's like
oh well oh it's hard to tell if
someone's on a cell phone if they're
what they're what they're talking about
there's no cell phones it's easy to tell
what they're talking about it was a huge
problem but for for U.S targeting
purposes I mean our enemy enemies often
understand our taxes better than we do
uh and obviously they're making
adjustments that's one of the things
they did there was blow up all the cell
towers so there's no network and we
can't use signal intelligence
um you know to to our advantage so
um that was a well-documented problem
and and something that we've been
briefed on before we even arrived in
ramadi I think that happened in 2005 you
know uh well before we got there in
2006. yeah you know you mentioned
earlier you know the my Rules of
Engagement brief you know my brief brief
which was hey if you have to pull the
trigger make sure the person you're
killing is bad
the
for me and this is a leadership
principle
what I need to do is keep my guys out of
trouble
that's what I need to do that's what I
told you you need to do you keep your
guys out of trouble and by the way this
doesn't only apply to combat this
applies to where on Liberty in
Louisville Kentucky or Reno Nevada or
Lake Tahoe or San Diego
our job as Leaders is to prevent our
guys from getting in trouble
it's not cover up when they get in
trouble it's actually prevent them from
getting in trouble we'll get into
cover-ups because cover-ups don't work
there's no such thing as a cover-up it's
just you're just getting I already
talked about it with with that uh case
that I that I mentioned when I was the
Admirals Aid that happened like if
you're covering things up you're making
it worse for everybody and we'll get to
that but our job as Leaders is to make
sure your guys don't get in trouble how
do you do that if my guys get in trouble
get an alcohol related incident
guess what that's my fault
it's actually my fault what did I do why
didn't I explain to them what they need
to watch out for why didn't I keep them
busy enough that they weren't out get
doing something stupid why didn't I make
sure they have a detonated driver or a
designated brain as we used to call it a
designated brain meaning hey it's not
just a person that's going to drive it's
the person that's going to think
so we got nine Knuckleheads going out
and getting drunk we got a tenth person
there that's a designated brain that
makes sure nobody does anything stupid
that's our job so it's our fault if we
allow people to get into trouble
that means if we don't explain the Rules
of Engagement if we don't explain an
admiral uh mcraven had a good way of
putting this if we don't draw the red
lines that you're not allowed to cross
very clearly so everyone understands
them we're allowing our guys to get in
trouble
that's what's going to happen
the same thing we talk about since day
one
being taking care of your people isn't
saying hey do whatever you want and I'll
cover for you that's not how you take
care of your people you want to take
care of your people you explain to them
what the rules are and what will happen
if they break the rules that's how you
take care of your people
you make sure they understand the Rules
of Engagement
and then on top of that they have to
understand why this is happening
they have to and this is what I would
explain
I would explain hey
this city is filled with civilians
this city is filled with civilians with
normal good Iraqi civilians it's filled
with doctors and teachers and imams
and the day that we go out and we kill a
doctor or a teacher and a mom out in the
city of ramadi
first of all we've done
irreparable damage to the war effort
we are not going to be able to take that
back this is a problem this is going to
get used by Al Qaeda it's going to get
used by the insurgents it's going to be
used for their propaganda that's what
they're going to show
so we've taken a huge negative strategic
step the day we go out and killing
innocent person also we're going to get
shot down
that's what will happen we go out and
kill a civilian some Imam or some doctor
or some teacher we're going to get shut
down we're not going to do any more
operations not one of our
military army Marine Corps Battalion
commanders would have allowed that to
fly ever
so we would have gotten shut down the
deployment would pretty much be over
and we would have been destroying what
we were actually fighting to protect
so when we're in a leadership position
it's our job to make sure that the team
understands all those consequences not
to mention you're going to go to prison
not to mention that part but all those
consequences they have to understand all
those consequences that's our job as
leaders
yeah I mean in that environment too like
there was you weren't getting away with
anything you know I mean there was this
is a city with 400 000 people they
there's a there's a a governor uh
there's a there's a in you know there's
infrastructure in place there's people
out on the street there was embedded
reporters that were out there on
operations I mean there was a CNN camera
crew with uh uh a number of the Marine
Army units that we worked with I
remember that specifically Stars and
Stripes supporters
um it was that stuff was was always out
there uh in fact we got busted for
patches because uh which we wrote about
in uh into economy leadership the I
couldn't even hide the patches from you
because there was a combat cameraman
that took some photos and the photos got
back for approval out there snapping
photos of of uh on operations so there's
always people out there always folks
with us every operation we did had had
an interpreter with us a civilian
um you know usually uh either either an
Iraqi citizen or or maybe an American
citizen who had grown up in Iraq these
were people that were with us on every
single operation this was their Homeland
they they loved these people there was
they were they were part of that on
every operation so I mean that was
something that we were uh uh that that
it was just the reality of of how we
were operating this wasn't just some
some like deep in the hinterland of
Afghanistan somewhere where no one's
going to know about this and there's no
roads in there or anything like that
this was a city with hundreds of
thousands of people
um and uh and and constant scrutiny on
every single operation that we did
I wanted to just talk about what you
just said which I think is is a really
powerful uh a powerful point and and you
know oftentimes as Leaders we talk about
what does it really mean to take care of
you people what does that mean and you
know as you said it's it is oftentimes
the the Trap is that people they want to
be like hey I wanna you know I'm gonna
hey you know yeah you got in a fight you
got a bar fight or hey you did something
you shouldn't have done on Liberty
um you know before we even deployed like
hey I want to be liked as a leader so
I'm not gonna actually hold the line or
I'm not gonna hold the stand or I'm
gonna I got your back I'm gonna cover up
for something that maybe you shouldn't
have done and you made it very clear
from the beginning I think it's one of
the most important things that you've
taught me
is
this my job as a leader my job as the
platoon Commander the officer in charge
is as much as anything else out there
not just planning and executing a
tactical Mission out there but is to
take care of my people by making sure
that they're doing the right things that
they understand the Rules of Engagement
that they're they're doing things not
not only from a perspective of you know
to make sure that they're everything
they're doing is is legal and moral and
ethical but also to make sure that
they're not going to harm our Strategic
Mission or do something that's gonna
gonna give our Al Qaeda you know in Iraq
uh terrorist enemies
propaganda to use against us or to
undermine us with a local local civilian
populace or to do something that they
might regret for the rest of their lives
and you really help me understand that
well taking care of my people met is is
looking out for their long-term good and
and the long term go to the mission and
and I think for me it it was it's a hard
thing but but as I've often said
you help me see that like my job that
was my job as a leader and and what I
you know you helped me you gave me the
confidence to know that instead of just
instead of just hey I probably should be
doing this I probably should be making
sure that the platoon shows up early and
gets their training done and you know if
somebody gets in trouble on Liberty
um instead of covering up for that or
saying hey we got your back man saying
hey man you're doing the enemy's job for
if if you get in trouble and you get
arrested you're giving the seal team's a
bad name you're not going to deploy with
us that doesn't help us that doesn't
help our mission and you got to think
about that and so you gave me the
confidence to know that like I I
actually have to be that's the leader
that I have to be and if I'm not doing
those things if I'm not looking out for
the long term go to my people making
sure that they're doing everything that
illegal and moral and ethical and
following the rules of engagement doing
not just what they think is right but
actually what's legal if they're not
doing those things then then I'm
actually failing as a leader and I'm
failing failing the team and so that
gave me the confidence to know that this
is absolutely black and white uh and and
that is my job as a leader is to keep my
people from do doing things that is that
are going to harm them put them in
Jeopardy you know that are illegal
immoral uh unethical but also things
that they might regret for the rest of
life things that might affect us and
harm our ability to build relationships
with a local populace and go out and
secure them stabilize the city lower
level of violence and that was my job as
a leader
I think one of the things that probably
I
utilized or maybe maybe connected the
dots for you and by the way a lot of
this stuff when I talk about this stuff
and it sounds it might sound like oh I
was this big thinker and I had
everything figured out that's not true
actually I look back and I feel once
again lucky because I feel like I was
just ahead of the curve I feel like I
just was far enough I was mature enough
I was old enough I had been through
enough I'd learned enough I'd had the
right mentors at the right times I'd
seen enough that I was just ahead of the
curve of being like hey this is our job
this is what we need to do and one of
the dots to connect
is
look if you're in the SEAL Teams
your job and the number one priority is
the mission look we take care of our
troops
but what our focus is what we do look we
take care of the troops but our action
the actions that we take should all be
driving towards one thing and that is
effectively executing our mission and
that as I've said before is the trump
card
[Music]
it's the trump card in any argument
you're gonna have with the team guy
when that when that team guy says well I
I want to go out tonight or I want to do
this dumb thing or I want to go make
this happen when when you say back to
them hey do you not want to be able to
go close with and destroy the enemy on
the battlefield
there's no answer there's no answer the
only answer is yes that's what I want to
do is this going to help you do that if
you get in trouble tonight for being
drunk if you get in a fight if you have
some kind of an issue with your freaking
credit card and your credit's bad and
you lose your security clearance all
those things
they're all bad and and hey I mean when
when we were in ramadi I said hey
anybody that [__] this up and you start
to do things that are Stu if you do
something that's stupid that's gonna
interfere with our opportunity to kill
the enemy to do our mission you're going
home immediately I don't want you here
you will not be here
and when you so when you talk about the
the confidence
the confidence is just you figuring out
oh
there's no arguing with that there's no
seal that says well actually I I'd
rather you know take the risk and
getting in trouble than than fight the
enemy there's no and if you do have a
seal like that get them out of your
platoon immediately kick him out kick
him out of the teams if you have
somebody that prioritizes
anything other than executing the
mission
then they're not in the right job
so I think connecting those dots was
very important
now you mentioned like oh they had a
government they had a governor there
so so just to take that a little bit
further there was a Government Center in
downtown ramadi there was a there was a
bureaucracy it was small but they had a
bureaucracy they had a governor I forget
his name but they had a governor and
this Governor that was running the city
of ramadi met with the Brigade Commander
two or three or four times a week had
sit-down meetings to say hey one of your
tanks drove over this bridge and now the
the cars can't go over it you need to
fix it and the Brigade Commander say yes
sir we'll take care of it the the
governor of ramadi would say hey
there was a a a Bradley Fighting Vehicle
that rolled through the front gate of
one of my people you need to get out
there and prepare that guy and the
Brigade Commander would say yes sir we
will take care of it Battalion Commander
would they get task go take care of that
gate when a civilian
got wounded or got killed well first of
all if Australian Got wounded they would
immediately cast back that person trying
to help but if there was a civilian that
got killed because this is war and
civilians did get killed in the Battle
of Modi it was a small number but they
did get killed when that happened
the governor would meet with the Brigade
Commander they would sit down they would
give reparations to the family
we would apologize as Coalition forces
and we would handle that so
when civilians got killed it was a huge
deal there was times actually a lot of
times
a lot of times there was times probably
three or four times that there was big
protests
where civilians had been killed and the
local populace came and protested hey
you you know Coalition forces killed one
of our you know one of our kids one of
our people one of our and and then we
had to go figure out what's going on
again I'm saying we the Brigade would
have to then go and figure out what
happened and sit down with the family
that had lost one of their family
members and pay reparations this was a
huge huge deal
so to think that you could be out there
just killing people was just it's just
completely insane thought it's a
completely insane thought it could it
could not happen every civilian casualty
was a catastrophe it was a it was a
problem that got raised through the
entire government of of ramadi and
brought to the Coalition forces and and
was solved it was investigated it was
reparations were paid that's what
happened every single time
so it's important to think about that as
you start to think about
the job that you and I had which was
making sure that our guys understood
that clearly so that they could make the
right decisions and what that all boiled
down to is make sure that if you pull
the trigger you better freaking make
sure that the person you're killing is
bad otherwise everything else is going
to fall apart
and you you made that absolutely clear
to us and uh I think that
you know that that it I remember one
particular time when I don't know if it
was soldiers or Marines but there had
been uh there'd be there was a protest
at the front gate over over a civilian
catchy that had happened
um on an operation that that this is one
that we we hadn't been a part of but I
remember hearing about it you talked to
me about it like this is what's gonna
happen if we're not following the rules
of engagement and what we were to a
point where I remember you and I
actually had a disagreement over the use
of explosive breaching charges based on
the the the impact of like hey if if
there's a family on the other side of
that door we could possibly injure
people let's let's don't use an
explosive breach and the thinking of
seals at the time was no you have to use
an explosive reaching charge and uh and
we I remember you and I had a big debate
about that like no actually
um use use manual tools
um let's uh let's let's try not to do
that that shouldn't be our standard
operating procedure so they we can
mitigate any potential risk of
collateral damage that might result and
there was a push back in the platoons on
that but when you explain to me why that
was important and you know what would
happen if if we accidentally injured a a
kid or you know a family member on the
other side of the the door then it made
total sense okay we need to we need to
back off using explosive breach of
charges we're going to use manual tools
so that we can put the security of the
popists we're willing to take some more
risk to ourselves in order to protect a
civilian populace to to make sure that
we don't cause you know unwarranted
collateral damage and that we don't give
the enemy some you know recruiting tool
to go out and say hey look the uh look
at look at what the Americans are doing
they're out killing innocent civilians
luckily for me I had already been
through that so those arguments that you
were bringing to me I had already been
through them on my last deployment I had
already been through the whole breaching
thing I already been through the
civilian casualties oh and how bad those
were for the war effort so when the
implication comes from life that I'm
being a freaking wimp right because
that's what it is you're like what do
you mean we can't explosively breach
what not you're being a wimp Jocko not
only that but now you're putting my guys
at higher risk because if we don't
breach the door and there's a bad guy
behind the door and we're sitting there
with a sledgehammer trying to open it
you're gonna get my guys killed
luckily for me I had already had all
these discussions before
and hey well how many times have you
taken rounds through the door on your on
your BR on your explosive breaching
charges you haven't how many times you
so we start having these discussions how
many times have you been engaged inside
the target building yeah I know you're
getting engaged a lot outside there how
many times you so we're having these
discussions
we're having discussions that these are
not actually black and white
that hey if you're hitting a Target
where you are deeming it as the
commander on the ground that is so high
risk that you feel the need to use
explosive reaching charge do it
do it but let that be a decision that
you're making and if you look at that
door and you say you know what
I don't think we need to do I don't
think we need an explosive breaching
charge right now don't use one and the
risk versus reward
we're gonna up the risk to our troops
yes
yes why because we're trying to
accomplish the mission and the mission
is to secure the population if you're
out there hurting and killing the
populace with explosive breaching
charges you're failing the mission
and go I'm sure you want to talk about
that one story where you made the call
you're you know you had a breacher that
was like Hey we're gonna blow this door
and you're assessing the situation you
see what the situation is and you said
no breach that was a tough situation
where my breacher wanted to put an
explosive charge on the door and uh and
and it probably made sense to him to be
able to do that and I I was because I
was detached I was back from the door
and I was observing the situation I saw
uh I saw a man's pair of sandals which
is the common Footwear they wear man
Spirit sandals woman's pair of sandals
kids kids kids kids like there was three
or four pairs of kid sandals next to
this door and it was kind of a small
room that we're about to go into
and and I just I told my lead breacher
who was a fantastic seal and an
incredible guy I was like I was like hey
let's put let's let's manually breach
that get the Sledge up here and he
wasn't too happy with me for that he was
like what are you talking about and we
almost we kind of got in in a back and
forth there
um and I kind of had to put my foot down
on that to like let's Sledge the door so
we we sled the door got in the room
we're able to capture the target uh that
we were after and and of course there
was a family right on the other side of
the door so it was the right call to be
made there
um but it was something that because
we'd had that discussion about about
we've got to be we have to be careful
about not injuring civilians on this
stuff and so taking a step back to be
wary of that and thinking about that and
and certainly it was a higher risk this
was a high level Al-Qaeda in Iraq bad
guy we had I think we pulled they were
they were he had beheading videos on DVD
uh this this was a really bad guy that
we're rolling after uh that he was
directly linked to some some horrible
you know torturing civilians and
murdering people and a number of attacks
um and so it was a risky move but I it
was the right call based on the
situation that we wanted to minimize
collateral damage yeah also because we'd
already cleared like other buildings it
wasn't like this was the initial breach
like it was
it was that's what it painted and you
know when you debrief debrief me on it I
was like yeah good call
but that that there also you did give me
the leeway to make decisions when I did
need a breach on things and there was
another situation where we were uh we we
were after a particular guy and we the
AC-130 Gunship over head observes him
jumping from one building to the next
building the next building the rooftops
were just a few feet apart so he was
able to jump from rooftop to Rooftop and
so we're chasing this guy I think we
have four or five buildings down and uh
and so we know where he is we we leave
the target Bill we're in we Patrol down
to hit that building we know this guy's
expecting us to be there we don't have
the element of surprise so we used an
explosive breach on that
um you know on that door and when we did
we blasted the door and we blew all the
windows out of the you know the front of
the building and as we it was it was a
call that I made based on like okay this
is a high threat guy
um he may absolutely have a weapon or a
suicide vest on him and we uh we're
gonna explosively reach the charge when
we went in to the room uh we locate he
was another room deep
lined up against the wall was the the
family and then uh what was interesting
about that was they stood up and
immediately pointed out the guy that was
like he's not one of us
um and do our interpreter uh and we
talked to this family I was like we're
very sorry for the damage to your door
the damage to your uh your your windows
um and and Through The Interpreter I'm
telling them we gave them we carried
serp funds with us which were I remember
what the acronym stands for but it was
it was a it was it was a fund that we
had available I would carry uh 500 on it
was it was like the standard certified I
would carry which went a long way in the
city of Vermont he's certainly to pay
for the damage that was done
um and the uh the head of the household
the man uh was said I I don't need your
money thank you for getting this bad guy
out of our neighborhood I think he'd
he'd tortured or murdered some of their
relatives and and friends and uh and
they were just happy for us to get get
this guy out of there which was that was
kind of the fur you know the the change
in most of the civilian populace that
had lived under that reign of of Terror
and fear under these insurgents of hey
we're actually happy to see you we
appreciate the work that you're doing
and we did sit in a simple Affairs team
out there and I think they prepared
their door and and uh fixed their
windows at least gave them some money
you know to do that but you gave me the
leeway to make the call but knowing that
uh when we we were gonna make the call
to try to minimize the collateral damage
uh that could possibly happen at every
opportunity uh and that was that was my
job as a platoon Commander was to be
detached and observe the situations and
make a decision based on what I was
seeing and to try to mitigate the threat
the risk that I could to my team but to
to also mitigate the risk to the
civilians and we we prioritize that over
the rest of our own team
yeah and the reason I was able to give
you and Seth a bunch of leeway
is because you knew and understood that
the decisions that the actions
that your platoon took under your
command were your actions and your
decisions and you had 100 ownership of
them you weren't going to be able to
come back and tell me oh the breacher
put a charge on the door and blew the
door and you know wounded a civilian it
was my breacher's fault that that wasn't
happening
you were gonna make decisions every
decision that got made was your decision
it's your platoon and by the way when my
my commanding officer came to me I
wouldn't say well leif's breacher did
this it's leif's fault or the breacher's
fault no it's on me I didn't explain
this clearly enough so the ownership
[Music]
up and down the chain of command is what
allows there to be that kind of
discretionary leeway and you had to have
it with your snipers I mean you can't
accept that to have it with his snipers
to say yeah if they're if you know the
person is doing something bad if you
know they're a bad person they have
hostile intent then you take the shot
you don't have to call me you have to
call Seth you take the shot that is
because everyone is taking ownership of
what is going on and and it goes
direct like when you're I mean we we
started this in workup you know when
your freaking Point man got lost
and you came back to me and said oh yeah
sorry my appointment got lost I didn't
go talk to your point man I talked to
you I said well did you did you go
through the the route with him did you
know what the landmarks were looking for
will you keep in Pace
because this is your platoon it's not
your point man Splatoon when you're a
machine gunner you know was outside of
his field shooting outside his Field of
Fire I wasn't like hey machine gunner
let me talk to you no life what is going
on with your machine gunner why didn't
you explain the fields of fire you're in
charge same thing with stoner stoner has
his freaking uh medic doing something
they shouldn't be doing
oh do I say oh medic come and talk to me
no hey Seth why is your medic doing this
right now why did they take that action
so
I I definitely
you know there's things can get a little
bit
I mean this can happen in any
organization but certainly in the SEAL
Teams
the SEAL Teams are tactically run by our
enlisted leadership our our platoon
Chiefs run the platoon
are our lpos run the Platoon
our senior enlisted Seas inside of a
troop run the troop they're they're
they're gonna make things happen
and it's pretty easy for an officer to
start thinking well you know the chief
made that call
maybe it's the chief's fault it's pretty
easy for that to happen and I had many
of these conversations when I was
running training when I was running
trade at many of these conversations you
know the the OIC would tell me well you
know the platoon Chief wanted to do this
so that's why we did it oh so it's a
platoon Chief you want to go talk to the
Future soon Chief overall in charge
and I know what I when I used to teach
that Junior officer training course I
would say
you know who's going to court marshall
on that decision it's not the platoon
Chief because it's your freaking platoon
you're the one that's going to answer
so making sure that people understand
that when you're in charge it's your
decision no matter who makes that
decision inside the platoon or inside
the team or inside the organization or
inside the company or inside the
department
when you're in charge of that department
when you're in charge of that division
that's your call and you're gonna have
to own it and that understanding for you
for Seth that's what allowed there to be
leeway
that's what happens that's that's
decentralized command
uh you have to have trust in order to
get there I have to make sure that
people understand the why
and and that's what allows us to to
handle those types of situations
now we talk about our Rules of
Engagement but the enemy
they understood our Rules of Engagement
as well and and they certainly adapted
because they have no Rules of Engagement
which is which is which is a huge
Advantage for them they don't care about
civilian casualties they don't care
about destroying the infrastructure they
don't care if they have blue on Blues
they literally don't in fact they have
suicide bombers they don't care about
any of that
so they understood our Rules of
Engagement and they did their best to
utilize our Rules of Engagement against
us
is tough to deal with
it was horrible to deal with and I think
I think that's you know they were uh
they were they came up with the most
diabolical way they could to try to kill
us
um you know in any way that they could
and they were incredibly adaptive very
Innovative always looking like probe for
weaknesses and and take advantage of uh
of where they saw weaknesses
um you know this this is they were
hiding amongst the civilian populace so
you've got you've got an individual out
there they're wearing a dishdasha uh and
uh which is kind of the Arabic robe and
you know might have a cafe wrapped
around their face which is like the
Arabic Arabic headdress
they're shooting at us with you know 100
round belt of of pkc machine gun uh
which is a Russian belt fit machine gun
and then and then they'd you know they
drop that weapon and now they're walking
on the street as a civilian so it was
um they would constantly try to Prey
Upon the the mercies and the moral High
Ground And The Rules of Engagement of uh
of our our U.S forces as well so
um I remember my first appointment when
there was a a a VB ID or a a car bomb
that was driven into a U.S Convoy and
and they used an elderly man to do that
and the the turret Gunner was did you
know was was reluctant to engage this
elderly man who's driving up he thought
maybe it was just the problem next you
know maybe he just didn't know what was
going on uh next you know he blows
himself up and kills a bunch of
Americans so they would always do that
kind of stuff they'd use spotters who
weren't armed you know they'd send them
out there look looking for uh uh in
enemy territory you'd have have somebody
who's looking around corner of the
building and you know that he's talking
to his buddy with an RPG that's standing
probably six feet to his his right
behind the behind the corner of the uh
of the building but you can't actually
see that guy so so we're not gonna We're
Not Gonna engage that the the spotter
um who's not armed but we know that that
we could you know we could use the
escalation of force to say warn him to
either get away utilize a warning shot
um in order to do that and uh but it was
it was they would they would have the I
mean the guys lined up and ready to go
and sometimes when we had multiple a
sniper OverWatch positions we got to see
that where they're they're gonna Attack
One OverWatch position and I would see
we're in another OverWatch position we
could see it from a different angle they
didn't realize that we were in one
position they knew where the other
position was and we'd see the behind the
scenes there as the spotters actually
looking out in the street and he's
talking to a guy there's there's two
there's two insurgents with with uh
belt-fed machine guns and and a two more
with RPG rockets that are ready to
launch and you could you could witness
that and see it happening yeah and by
the way that's hostile intent that
spotter's getting killed you know you
you that's that's we killed spotters
that were doing exactly that and I
remember the first time because we and
when we'll get into this but
we had to send up shooter statements of
who is engaged and why they're engaged
and I remember the uh The Siege sotif
asking about hey this is an unarmed
person
uh that's just observing and giving
directions and I said no they're
coordinating I remember I remember
writing this this email up the chain of
command when a person is you know giving
passing uh coordinating instructions to
active military aged males that are
armed they are not just Gathering
intelligence they are coordinating
attacks and they are going to die and I
got the reply back Roger because it was
absolutely warranted that's that's what
the enemy was doing they were those
spotters were out there coordinating
attacks and in order to disrupt those
attacks they needed to die and so that
was a
that's the way that's the way we had to
operate and it wasn't but just real
quick it wasn't like
it wasn't like uh someone was out bird
watching you you wouldn't see someone it
didn't look casual like people might
think oh you might get mixed up oh how
do you know it's obvious it's so obvious
they're they're it's hostile intent
hostile act you can see it
any seven-year-old kid could watch and
go oh that person's doing something bad
and then you take a trained military
person that's been observing this enemy
TTP for the last one month two months
three months they're gonna get it every
time yeah and and to to paint the
picture for what that looks like you're
patrolling down the street all of a
sudden you just I would never observe
like the civilians leaving all of a
sudden it would just click in my mind
like hey they're they're gone as we said
before all of a sudden the Street's
empty and then you gotta then you got
some money around the corner who's like
you know the peeking around the corner
and looking and watching you and you you
know you're about to eat an RPG rocket
or have some 100 rounds of you know
machine gun bursts come coming your
direction any any moment and uh it was
obvious that that was
every justification for a reasonable
certain fossil intent in the OverWatch
positions though they often use they
would send out like a teenage kid and
this was something where they they would
send out a teenage kid to like knock on
the doors knock on the gates because
sometimes they would know we were in
there somewhere you know some enemy
Fighters got shot and killed they're
shooting back but they're not exactly
sure where we are but they're kind of
narrowed it down to a group of buildings
on this block and they send a 12 13 year
old kid who's not unarmed like knocking
on the gates
um and you know exactly what they're
doing and and you know they're trying to
figure out where you are but in that
case no nobody we were gonna just kill
some kid uh what we did was either
ignore them uh not answer the gate or in
some cases uh we had a we'd have The
Interpreter go out there covering for
them with like the man of the house talk
to him briefly uh or in some cases we
detained the the uh the kid obviously
they're gonna know exactly where we were
you know at that point but but when
didn't we didn't engage that kid we knew
that they were that kid was being used
as as you know probably through no fault
of his own and they're they're taking
and putting this teenager at risk
um you know to try to find out where we
were so they could kill us and and try
to Prey Upon you know our mercies uh but
we we follow the rules of engagement in
that regard and we would
um those kids didn't get engaged we knew
that we were in a position that we were
about to about to get attacked and we
would uh defend that position what we
would sometimes attain that kid uh or
sometimes just ignore them or sometimes
have the you know the senior family
member talk to him and
um and tried to try to dissuade them in
some way but you you knew that attack
was coming
um and it was something that we just had
to be had to be prepared for
um but we followed the Rules of
Engagement yeah and
there's no and I remember explaining
this there's nothing that Al Qaeda wants
more
than for us to kill a kid there's
nothing that they want more for their
propaganda than for us to kill a woman
us to kill a kid us to killing a mom us
to kill a doctor that's what they want
they couldn't get make a doctor walk out
there and do that they couldn't make it
a mom do that but they could they could
force a 12 year old or 13 year old kid
to walk down the street knocking on all
the doors they were hoping and praying
that we would shoot them and then they
have their big propaganda Victory so
why are we making how can we make these
decisions it's because we're thinking
about what's going on we're thinking
from a strategic perspective we also
know like you said I mean uh the the
enemy doesn't know right now they're
gonna know in about 20 minutes they're
gonna figure it out
so it's not like you're gonna it's not
like you're taking some tactical some
huge tactical loss where you're going to
be in a extremely compromised position
now that you've been compromised by this
kid that's not happening so there's no
value there's no value at all and and
again thinking about the Strategic value
of letting that kid live is
in infinitely more important than the
Tactical value of not them not knowing
we're there for another 10 minutes but a
matter of fact you engage the kids now
they know exactly where you are yeah
there's a lose-lose situation no
tactical Advantage from doing that
whatsoever and uh and that's exactly
what they want us to do 100 and we knew
that
um and and we weren't going to do that
but more importantly like that's not
something anybody wants to carry on
their crotches obviously the the
immorality of that that's that's just
not who the the guys that we serve with
are and uh and so that that's not
something that that we we would have
done and and didn't do uh because
um again my my job as as as the platoon
Commander out there was to make sure
that people weren't doing something that
was gonna was illegal immoral unethical
or get them in trouble or something they
would care on their conscience for the
rest of their lives so uh that's
something that I took very seriously
that and and it's it's uh even though
our enemies tried to Prey Upon that
that's something that we were not going
to give them also thinking about the
fact that they the enemy
literally used human Shields and and
utilized these like these 12 year olds
that were talking about walking solo
down the street
the enemy also
literally used and literally gets used
all the time but actually used children
as human Shields
yeah we saw that a number of times and
we're talking like an Insurgent fighter
carrying an RPG rocket over their
shoulder who's holding a child you know
a little 10 year old girl in front of
him as a human shield and again that's
they want us to shoot them they they
want us to shoot them so they can use
that as as propaganda as I said I feel
like these insurgents were as evil as
any enemy that that America's ever faced
in our long military history and it's
because of stuff like that it's just
just horrible horrible stuff what was
awesome about that though is that you
know if you're a if you're a you know a
army private or a marine private man and
a machine gun 50 cal and you engage in a
surgeon like that you're very likely to
hit the the uh you know the human shield
the 10 year old girl is being used as a
human shield our seal snipers were able
to regularly engage insurgents headshot
on those insurgents eliminate the threat
without actually injuring the kids and
they did that a number of times and it
was something that I know the army
marines are very appreciative of and I
was I was impressed with the skill and
discipline of our seal snipers who were
scrutinizing those shots and able to
able to save the lives of kids that
these evil insurgents are utilizing as
human Shields as they're running across
the street you know uh and just you know
do no further on this kid it's just
being dragged along you know in a horror
knowing that they're probably going to
get shot and killed and a SEAL Sniper
would be able to eliminate the Insurgent
and that kid's able to go run home with
their family and not be killed yeah
props and and salute to the the snipers
and the nsw which is the the naval
special Warfare sniper school and just
the training that they got those guys
got put through and how just outstanding
they were and how how
focused they were on that craft to be
able to execute shots like that it's
just awesome so we had I also want to
point out
that although there was 400 000
civilians there and although there was
civilians you know in the populace there
was also an incredible amount of
legitimate targets and
when we arrived as you pointed out the
the enemy wasn't used to Americans being
in these neighborhoods they weren't used
to it at all they weren't used to
Americans being concealed in OverWatch
positions they weren't used to Americans
being able to take accurate long-range
shots down long axis roads it was a
Target Rich environment
and the enemy killed in action the
numbers of enemy killed in action were
big
were high right out of the gate and what
that did is
immediately we got a lot of eyes on what
we were doing a lot of examination a lot
of inspection and even some scrutiny in
the beginning which is fine
we got a lot of scrutiny on what we were
doing because the number of enemy killed
so quickly hadn't been that we really
hadn't had that that those High numbers
since Vietnam
since Vietnam that there was just a
killing going on on a daily basis Enemy
being killed reports coming up so the
chain of command
dug in and and looked at what we were
doing they started to
they started to say hey what's going on
and our attitude was come and see
that's that's just and and this is
something I actually learned from the
Army was
come and investigate come and come and
look at what we're doing come and see
what we're doing come on out here you
want to send the you know whoever from
the chain of command you want to send
the office off you want to send the CMC
you want to send anybody that you want
to come out send come out you want to
send out our Jag send them on out we'll
bring them out so they can actually see
what's going on and
and those then they did so they come out
this is exactly what we're doing and
then they put some things on us that
were
seemed a little bit rigid but if you
thought about them
they actually made sense things like
like sworn shooter statements
yeah and that was something that I I got
frustrated with initially because we
were getting some scrutiny who wave got
frustrated
angry late uh well and when you think
about it from my perspective if I know
that my snipers are out there as I just
said that use using incredible judgment
incredible discipline minimizing
collateral damage to the to as much as
they possibly can in every situation and
yet protecting you know the civilian and
a typical sniper OverWatch you might
have it's it's a city you might have
three or four hundred people walk in
front of your sniper scope and they're
engaging an enemy fighter who's carrying
an AK-47 and another guy with an RPG
rocket that's clearly either attacking
us or maneuvering uh to attack a nearby
friendly Patrol and so we would we would
write that up uh and and in in these
sworn shooter statements and the Jag the
military lawyer at the the siege of sort
of headquarters uh which was was two
levels up the chain of command for us
and they were like 80 miles away led to
the north
um where it was so they're not with us
they don't know what's going on there
they would sometimes ask some questions
and I got very defensive about that and
just an example you might I might have a
a statement that said you know two
military age males carrying AK-47s were
engaged resulting in two enemy killed in
action and so the Jag would would ask
some questions of like hey why did you
engage these guys it's like well they're
carrying AKs they're attacking people
obviously but in under the rules there's
no banks in Iraq so each of each of the
household was allowed to have a one
weapon per
um per I think the senior male per
household so one weapon per uh senior
male per household and that's their
their home defense because they have all
their valuables under their bed or you
know tucked in a corner somewhere or any
money that they had there's no no banks
again so uh so the the the Jag is simply
saying well how do you know that these
weren't people just out for a stroll
um and so I got real defensive to say
well how dare your question my guys
you're trying to send them to prison for
doing our job was my initial reaction
and then as I talked to Jocko Jocko's
like yeah they're not here with us right
now
um they're 80 miles away they're not on
the ground with us now in the
battlefield so how are they supposed to
actually know what's going on there's a
legitimate question if they're allowed
to have an AK-47 how do you know it's
not somebody so I realized that I needed
to explain to the Jack why we were doing
that with those shooter statements and
uh and so
um and so what what I did was simply
realize okay if I'm a Jag and I'm
sitting in sandbagged headquarters and
I've never been on a comet operation and
I don't really I actually know what's
going on then I actually need to explain
it so I I we we made sure that those
shooter statements capture what actually
happened which was you know with a 22
power magnification night horoscope from
250 yards of SEAL Sniper observed two
military-age males carrying AK-47s in an
apparent attack in accordance with known
enemy tactics techniques and procedures
on a nearby friendly U.S Marine in Iraqi
Patrol
determine a reasonable certainty of
Hospital debt and engage with two route
two rounds of 300 Win Mag resulting in
two enemy killed in action because
that's actually what happened but as we
described that to the jab the Jag was
like awesome good shot awesome keep
doing doing what you're doing uh but
that scrutiny was real and and it
certainly we felt the pressure of that
um initially and uh and and as we hoped
the the Jags see why we're making
decisions we're making and explain to
them the situation uh that was going on
um those the questions they understood
what we were doing they understood why
we're doing they just they simply wanted
to make sure that we were following the
rules of engagement and uh and and so
you helped me realize that that they
were actually there to help us not our
enemy trying to put us in prison you
know for out doing our job they're
actually trying to help us to make sure
we're following the rules of engagement
and that's what we did by explaining
that to them
um and by making sure that those shooter
statements actually described what the
situation was and why it happened yeah
and and them not being there it seemed
unnecessary at first because for us on
the ground we knew that if a civilian
was killed the the
civilian populace was going to go wild
the government officials were going to
know and immediately send that up to
chain of command for we knew we had
Iraqi Soldiers with us we we had Iraqi
Soldiers with us on every almost every
single 98 of operations we did we had
Iraq it's probably more but we had Iraqi
Soldiers with us they're not going to
just watch as civilian Iraqis are
getting killed we had Iraqi interpreters
as you mentioned that are out there
they're watching us take shots we had
you know and someone was Jordan some
were Lebanese but they saw who were
killing
we had conventional forces that are out
there every single day interacting with
the local populace trying to build
relationships they're they're trying to
win the hearts and minds and now all of
a sudden we're just going out and
shooting civilians like it was insane
for us to think that that could be
happening
and like killing and a civilian
or an unarmed person was really just
totally unacceptable on all fronts the
Iraqi Army the Iraqi ramadi government
the US Army the Marine Corps our guys
and so when you're when you have all
that and someone goes hey we need to
know we need to know why you killed this
person like what are you talking about
so I was like okay we need to just take
a step back why are they asking those
questions well it's because they're not
here
and that's why that attitude of come and
investigate come with us come down and
see what we're doing I learned this from
the Army I learned this from the first
the 506 they had some they had some
incident happen and they were like hey
come and come and look at what happened
do you want to know what happened come
and look
and raise your hand and say come and
investigate if you think we're doing
something wrong or if we think we did
something wrong raise your hand and say
hey come and investigate this we need a
second set of eyes and that is a totally
positive things totally positive thing
and we did that and we got investigated
and it was like oh here's the outcome
here's here's what you did here's why
you did it you followed the Rules of
Engagement here's what was uncovered
okay cool there were so so
if you're operating within the Roe which
is what we stuck to
and you can articulate that and you do
articulate that properly and the
investigation shows yeah you followed
the Roe you engage the target as you
should you have nothing to hide you have
you have you only say this is what's
happening so it was actually great and I
look back now I'm so happy that we did
those shooter statements I'm so happy
that when we got investigated we got
investigated because then it's like Yep
this is what we did this is why we did
it and the other thing is
uh
you know clearly if you're doing things
and you're not doing the right things
you're going to jail like you're going
and you're getting shut down you're
going to jail that's what's gonna happen
but when you if you and if you cover it
up
it's gonna get even worse it's gonna you
know learning from that event with in
2005 thank God I learned that event look
I'm not saying I would have been doing
nefarious things but it made it very
easy for me to explain to you
and your guys and SAS guys hey if you
try and cover something up you're gonna
get burned there's no such thing as a
cover-up doesn't work
it doesn't work and there was there was
there was no way that you were gonna
actually hide hide that I mean as we
said for all the reasons you know we
have this huge civilian populace you
have embedded reporters that are out of
operations uh you have Iraqi soldiers
that are worthy for all the reasons that
you said
um it was unacceptable to go out there
and kill civilians we're trying to
protect the civilians we're trying to
actually uh build the relationship and
secure them uh so that ultimately we can
win in this counter-searchy fight and
you know that's something you taught me
the big cover-up is always wrong it's
always wrong I remember that statement
and you know one of the biggest lessons
that we brought back to help young
leaders after that time in ramadi to
pass on to the next generation of seals
as as you were running training and I
was running training to say hey this
temptation like you think taking care of
your people means that like you're gonna
have their you you you let them know you
you have their back no matter what then
that's totally wrong the worst thing
that you can ever do is help is it the
worst thing you can ever do as a leader
is let your people know or even think
that you're gonna have their back no
matter what
because we made it absolutely clear that
like look if you can articulate a
reasonable certainty of hustle intent we
got your back all day long if you can't
do that
then then I don't have your back and
that's why we got to follow the rules of
engagement this is why this is black
rats why we have to follow this
engagement and the cover-up stuff you
know the the idea that like
so it's it's a temptation of like hey I
don't want an investigation if you know
if this thing happened or if that thing
happened I don't want an investigation
on us hey we'll just you know we'll just
we'll just uh like like the the example
that you used hey we'll fire the weapon
of the wall and drop the weapon on the
guy and say hey this is you know this is
totally good to go and it's not and it
is that if if instead what you have to
do is say hey we shot a civilian you
know this is why we made that decision
here's why uh we had a reasonable
certain impossible intent you're going
to get an investigation there's going to
be an investigating officer you're going
to you're going to uh uh file statements
and and a Jag and actually this is uh
this is what we're going to do in order
to protect us to show everybody that
that this is actually um that this was
done in in the correct manner in the
course of the Rules of Engagement and it
was a very interesting way of looking at
those investigations because I didn't I
didn't I didn't I never want to be
investigated I want to protect my people
and I wanted to have their back as a
leader you know that's that's where you
go and you help me see that no come and
investigate come and investigate look at
this and we had a situation happen where
uh you know we had a uh an individual we
were sitting in a sniper OverWatch
position we had an individual
come in the gate we'd zip tied the gate
and so we went in there night time off
the boats from the river so this was a a
big compound there was there was uh
there was some some mobile buildings in
this compound and the buildings had been
um vacated so they had been lived in it
looks like not too long ago but there
was there was no one in them at the time
we were occupying them so we have
multiple overwatches we'd zip tied the
gates and we thought we had zip tied the
entire gate we didn't realize that there
was a walk-in gate we just zip tied the
vehicle gate the larger gate that opened
and there was a walking gate so we had
the sun had coming up come up we were
observing this was ahead of a big
operation that was going to happen with
the Marine Corps in a very bad area of
ramadi where they couldn't even get to
us without some massive uh clearance
operations dig the IEDs out of the road
and the boat certainly couldn't get out
there on the daytime as well because
they would have gotten shot off the
river
but so that the sun comes up uh we
engage some targets they're shooting in
us they we knew that the insurgents knew
where our position was and as uh all of
a sudden
I hear all of my cybers yell hey
someone's in the compound there was an
individual had opened a a a walk-in gate
that we had not seen at night time uh to
zip tie they'd opened a walking gate and
pushed so it's a it's a it's a military
age male pushing a
wheelbarrow full of heavy equipment uh
and it clearly was Heavy He's pushing it
up against he pushes it right up against
the building and
the the SEAL Sniper that was observing
this comes off a sniper rifle grabs his
M4 rifle and engages his individual
because he has a reasonable certainty of
Hospital intent that this is a guy who's
playing an IED up next against the
building which just real quick
that's a absolute executed tactic
technique and procedure by the enemy the
enemy at this juncture we had known
before we were there and while we were
there if there was snipers in an
OverWatch position they would the enemy
would put IEDs outside that building so
when the sniper team went to leave they
would get IEDs clacked off on them and
in fact
within days
of this operation that you're talking
about
the Marine Corps had gotten blown up on
x-fill I think they had two killed and
like three wounded like like I mean that
happened a matter of fact I briefed that
I briefed that
as one of the points of hey we need to
be watching out for this this is what
they're doing now so all that's in this
particular sniper's head he sees someone
putting a wheelbarrow up against the
building that you're in he's probably
getting ready to clock off an IED so
yeah he made the decision took the shot
and he makes a split second edition he
literally has like seconds as the gate
opens this guy trucks his wheelbarrow in
and this has been a guy who was he had
been observing our position he'd been
talking to a group of people and
pointing in our Direction
um it was a guy that we've been watching
and again we've been shot at uh so they
we knew they they knew our position so
he he drops it he he brings the
wheelbarrow right up next to the
building and the sniper engages them we
go out there and uh and as our EOD uh
bomb technician is looking uh at looking
at this wheelbarrow uh I mean this
wheelbarrow is full of like heavy
equipment there's like there was like a
sandbag uh or like burlap sack filled
with piping material with wires coming
out of it and and uh and as he's looking
at that
it's it's not an ID we can't there's no
explosive there it looks extremely Shady
uh you know from every every uh angle
and yet as he's actually looking at it
and he's meticulously you know looking
at it it's it's it ends up not being an
ID so we have uh I don't know what that
individual is doing I'm pretty dang sure
that he was probing us
um and uh and that if even if that
wasn't her idea he was gonna maybe he
was maybe the Insurgency said go see how
close you can get take this wheelbarrow
because the next time it was going to be
an ID to see if that was a viable tactic
I don't know I don't know if we'll ever
know all we know is now we have uh we
have a individual who is wounded uh and
what we thought was an ID isn't an ID
and so what we did was bring that guy
inside and our seal Corman who's got
some incredible life-saving skills goes
to work on that guy does everything he
can to try to save that individual
um and in accordance with the Rules of
Engagement and according to the Geneva
Convention yeah and law of arm conflict
so this is what we have to do as uh as a
um you know in accordance with all that
and and so um and it was the right thing
to do so the the seal corm is expending
our life-saving uh medical equipment to
try to save this guy's life
um and did everything he could and uh
just because of the gravity of his
wounds we are not able to save him
um but uh we we we called that into the
Marine Corps
um and uh and so we actually had two
different investigations uh because of
that it was through our own Special
Operations Command and we had a marine
uh investigation that was conducted we
we sat down with the Jags we talked
about it after that operation was
concluded
um and uh and we brought that individual
back we we brought and delivered him to
um uh to to the Marine Corps so that his
his body could be recovered and given
back to his family and reparations made
um in you know in every way that they
could they could make them and those two
investigations uh both cleared us to
show that the SEAL Sniper would act in
accordance with the Rules of Engagement
he had a reasonable certainty of hostile
intent as you said those Marines had
just experienced something very similar
to that where a bomb was planted right
next to their building
um and and killed a couple Marines and
wounded several others so it was uh it
was it was an unfortunate and horrible
situation that happened but we did
everything we could to try to save that
guy
um and and this is the realities of war
that even when you try to minimize
collateral damage there were things like
that that happened and when it does
happen you don't try to cover it up or
try to make it sound like something it
wasn't or plan a weapon on the guy or
pretend like it didn't happen because
everyone would have known about it
everyone would have known about that
what you do is is is take the
investigation come investigate see what
happens this is why this decision was
made in accordance with the Rules of
Engagement we it required a bunch of
interviews it requires sworn statements
uh and and ultimately we were cleared as
a result of that that it was a it was It
was a a shot that was taken in
accordance with the Rules of Engagement
because there was a reasonable certainty
of hostile intent in that situation
so young leaders old leaders I don't
care if you're the that story right
there is just so important for people to
understand it's so important especially
military law enforcement that story
right there is so important for for you
to understand
the move is
this is what happened come investigate
that's the move like you just said to
say okay hey let's plant some explosives
on hey breacher give us some of your
breaching charges and we'll we'll make
it look like he had explosives give him
a weapon put a put an old AK in his
wheelbarrow any of those things then
then we won't get if you make that move
you are going to get busted and
rightfully so you're you're it's gonna
get found out they're gonna go oh he had
explosives oh this is American Express
oh this is that this this uh serial
number goes back to your task unit so
this is you or the weapon oh the guy up
the street said this weapon was taken
from his house by you four days earlier
you're getting busted or the whatever
you are not or somebody in the in the
platoon or somebody in the Marine Corps
is I saw that guy get shot and then I
saw those guys you know or somebody with
a cell phone was sitting there recording
or with a camera any of these things
that's what's gonna happen
and you're screwing yourself and you're
screwing your guys over
by trying to cover this up and by lying
about it
so number two don't do that
I'm saying number two because number one
has to have already taken place and
number one is you make sure that your
troops know that if you do something
that is immoral unethical or illegal you
will not have their back
hey if they do something that is
that is within the Rules of Engagement
if they're doing the right thing for the
right reasons
not only do you have their back you will
die for them that's what the SEAL Teams
is
you you you you I will die for you
you're my brother
but if you do something that's illegal
immoral or unethical I don't have your
back anymore and and you know what I
used to tell guys there's nothing I can
do for you
there's nothing I can do for you you oh
you like me because I'm I'm gonna help
you out I'm helping you uh with your
getting to the right schools and I'm
helping you with your evaluations and
I'm helping you with your career and you
did something stupid over the weekend
we're gonna bring it up the chain of
command we're gonna get it taken care of
I'm helping you you do something that's
immoral illegal or unethical I can't
help you I remember that actually used
to scare guys a little bit because I had
a lot of I had a lot of clout if you did
some dumb [__] you did some stupid stuff
you got into you got into some little
incident out there I'm gonna get it
taken care of I am
I am I'm gonna take care of you you
getting some trouble you make a mistake
you should do something that you
shouldn't have done you stepped outside
the box a little bit okay look there's
gonna be some price to pay
but we're gonna get it squared away
but if you do something that's immoral
that's illegal that's unethical
I'm not gonna be able to help you and
I'm not going to help you
so that's step one and actually the way
Admiral mcraven was talking about like
there's red lines you go outside these
red lines there's nothing I can do for
you there's nothing I can do for you
anymore
you're on your own you need to know that
where guys where leaders slip up is they
don't want to say that
they don't want to say that because it
kind of sound like I mean even even
sitting here in this room with you my
brother Leif Babin saying like hey I got
your back to a point doesn't feel right
doesn't feel right it's like you'd be
like what do you mean you got my back to
a point
hey the here's the here's here's how
this comes full circle the way that I
have your back a hundred percent is by
making sure that you know what the rules
are and what lines you cannot cross and
if you cross them you're on your own
that's what we're talking about this is
the Crux of what we're talking about and
you as a leader have got to say that
you have a leader as a leader that's
step number one to make sure that the
team realizes that there's lines that if
they cross you will not have their back
because they're doing something that
they shouldn't be doing
and the honor of our country and the
honor of the teams trumps your stupidity
or your
your your
nefarious behavior and I don't got you
anymore
that's where leaders mess up
they don't they don't clarify that and
that crushes them
um
I
always felt comfortable because I know
that you guys do that and that's you
know like whatever it is me you know
you know you know there's you know
there's lines
yeah everybody knows there's lines with
me you know not to cross them you know
there's certain things if you do it
you're [__] I will I will destroy you
I will I will hate you you know if you
do something that gets our platoon
in some situation where we don't go to
war I'm going to hate you for forever
and I'm probably gonna try and kill you
within the Rules of Engagement within
the Rules of Engagement but but you know
what I'm saying it's like listen
everyone understood me in the fact that
the most important thing to me was we
have a job to do and we are going to do
this job and look part of doing this job
is we take care of our troops how do we
take care of our troops we make sure
that they understand what the rules of
engagement are they understand if they
cross those rules engagement there
there's nothing I can do for them
there's nothing you can do for them
there's nothing anyone can do from them
they're on their own
I I think what's so powerful for me for
that Jocko is it was
as I was saying earlier like that it
just crystallized on my mind like this
is black and white and I remember you
saying you know that that's that's what
that's what good leadership actually is
you're screwing me over if if I think
hey I'm just get away whatever I want
Jaco's got my back we're gonna cover it
up you're actually setting me up for
failure absolutely and and disaster for
me for the platoon for our mission for
everything uh and I think you you just
crystallized my mind like that is
no that's that's what you do as a leader
that's what you do that's what good
leadership looks like so that I could
execute with 100 confidence you know and
I remember the the you telling us when
we're talking about Rules of Engagement
we said it was black and white the words
that you used were because I remember
coming up in the Naval Academy
you know I would be told things like
well you know you got to do the right
thing because it's the right thing to do
and when you're on the battlefield the
right thing can it's it's kind of it's
kind of hard to determine sometimes when
you're fighting against an evil enemy
and I remember what you would say was
you can't do what you think is right you
have to do what's legal and so it made
it totally crystal clear in my mind and
for us and tasking a Bruiser out there
of like okay what is legally what do you
have to do in this situation so we we're
gonna we're gonna do the thing that is
legal and moral and ethical so we're
gonna do what's right and legal that's
that makes it clear in my mind and it it
helps me understand decisions I have to
make not only me but for everybody else
in the platoon for those in dealt
platoon for all of task in Bruiser and
then you taught that to the next
generation of seal leaders I've already
given that brief every time you came in
you know for the the junior officer
training course the leadership program
that I was running to all of the the
seals that you train through three years
of training you know to pass these
lessons on of like that is your job as a
leader yeah is to make sure that your
people are following the rules are not
doing stupid [__] that's gonna that's
going to you know get them sent to
prison for the rest of their lives
impact our mission uh and cause
strategic damage uh to our mission our
our tarnish the Legacy and Heritage of
the SEAL Teams and that was something
that you you crystallize in my mind uh
and that I went going forward knowing I
knew exactly what I needed to do as a
leader in order to maintain that
standard and it was very black and white
yeah you know I've been talking a lot
lately about the mob mentality that the
that the team has any team you know
company whatever they've got this mob
mentality working and that mob will
start to do things as a mob and you as a
leader can't be in the mob you can't be
in the mob because then you can't tell
which direction they're going sometimes
they're going in a great direction and
you you can just sit back and you can
encourage them let them go but when they
start going in the wrong direction
you're the one that has to pull the
reins and this doesn't matter you know
we could have a sales team that's
starting to sell a bunch of stuff and
they're making some good deals but
they're starting to cut margins and if
you're part of that we're hitting
records and like yeah we're gonna sell
the most we ever sold this month and
you're all excited about it with the
rest of the team all of a sudden you're
losing money
you can't do that you have you can't be
inside that mob you've got to be stepped
out to say Hey listen I know we want to
break records this month on our sales
but our margins are getting too low
we're not going to be profitable we're
going to lose money
the other the opposite thing could
happen too where the team's not making
good sales and they're all bummed out
and they're not not being proactive and
aggressive in their sales so you can't
be bummed out too you got to say Hey
listen we got this many days left in
this month here's some things we're
gonna do to make things happen I just
talked to the boss we're going to cut
margins a little bit more so we can get
improve our price point
but if you're in the mob
you can't do that and then and this goes
back to our earlier conversation and now
we get back to combat you have to have
the moral strength to say hey we can't
do this here's the red line if you cross
this red line you don't have my support
anymore and as a matter of fact you're
gonna get arrested and that's what's
gonna happen
if you don't make that clear as a leader
you're you're absolutely failing and I
think
that
with with us everybody knew and
understood this and I think that's what
was powerful and that's why I was so
appreciated by the Army in the Marine
Corps the Army in the Marine Corps had
us out there on you know they wanted us
to support every operation that they did
the reason because we had the most
squared away well we we look I'm not
going to compare not not the most we had
they knew they could count on us to make
the right decisions out there on the
battlefield they knew that with with the
highest percentage of certainty they
knew if we had an incident that happened
like you're talking about what would we
do we would raise our hand and say this
is what happened just like in the
opening chapter of extreme ownership
that you know who knew about that Blue
on Blue when it happened you know who
had figured out what it had gone down
you know who knew what had happened one
person me
me I'm the one that actually said oh
this was a blew up no one else knew no
one else knew
and what did I do went back to the
Battalion commander and said Hey sir
this was a Blue on Blue this was this
was a Blue on Blue this is what happened
I explained it to him
I actually didn't have to do that I
actually didn't have to do it and you
know what eventually it would have come
out most likely but and I would look
like a real jackass and I would have
been in prison
but to say hey
here's what happened
I know what happened and here's how it
went down okay got it
when you start covering stuff up you're
terrible so the Army the Marine Corps
they knew that they could count on us
they could count on us to do the right
thing and they could count on us if we
made some kind of a mistake
what we would do is raise our hand and
say hey here's what happened please come
and investigate
so we can make sure it doesn't happen
again
and and that's why they had us
conducting operations until the day we
left we conducted operations that entire
time the the conventional forces trusted
us implicitly with hundreds and hundreds
of shots taken hundreds and hundreds of
enemy killed with precision and
lethality and all the while
protecting the local populace
and that's what you do
when you understand
and you lead
that's how you maintain the moral High
Ground
you take ownership of what you do you
take preemptive ownership you know that
you're the one that's going to be
responsible
and then you do the right thing you do
the legal thing you do the lawful thing
that's that's how you can come back and
hold your head high and say we did what
we're supposed to do
and that's how you can be be proud of
what you did
and you know that's the one one of the
things you hear these
um the the news media is out there books
are out there articles are out there
and
what what really is terrible about those
things is the incredible sacrifices that
were made
incredible sacrifices that were made
and you think you know you think about
all those soldiers and Marines in the
Battle of Vermont you think a task in a
Bruiser the sacrifices that were made
and for you know people to say oh well
there's they were killing civilians it's
it's it's disgusting it's actually
disgusting speaking of speaking of the
moral low ground like to to propagate
that type of information would it just
it's sickening
um
but
lessons can be learned and I'm glad we
were able to get together because I I
know
like I said I feel like I was ahead of
the power curve just a little bit I was
ahead of that crest of the wave I was
lucky enough to have a very
lucky career I happened to go to Iraq at
the right time I happened to do a bunch
of operations I happened to work for the
Admiral I happened to be a prior
enlisted guy I happened to be a freaking
English major all those things I happen
to have a good understanding right at
the right time
do you happen to come work for me you
happen to be humble enough to listen to
what I had to say Seth happened to be
humble enough to listen to what I had to
say the platoons happen to have the
respect for you guys that denod their
head and say yeah this makes sense
so you add those things together that's
leadership
and it's hard
but
it all boils down to that idea
you have to maintain the moral High
Ground you have to you have to
and you do that by taking ownership
preemptive ownership of what you do if
something goes wrong you take ownership
of that
and then as you mentioned you do the
right thing
the legal thing the lawful thing the
ethical thing
and then you don't have to worry about
anything else
with that
any other comments life it's a heavy
subject it is a heavy subject but I
could tell you that uh
I couldn't be more proud of the
incredible seals that I serve with and
task at a Bruiser and uh and how they
conducted themselves on the battlefield
I mean it just what an extraordinary
group of men uh and to honor my lifetime
you get to serve alongside them uh and
uh an incredibly difficult and violent
Battlefield and they went out day after
day and put their lives on the line and
some sacrificed their lives like Mikey
monsor and Mark Lee and and Ryan Jobe
and uh and I think the just the how they
conducted themselves in the midst of
that battle was something I'll always be
proud of you know the discipline that
they used how they follow the rules of
engagement the collateral damage that
they minimize and the impact that they
had as a result of that and uh it's uh
it's definitely something I'm proud of
and uh and we can be proud of that
because
um because we understood the Rules of
Engagement and we had more High ground
and we maintain the more High Ground
um and uh and we knew we were on the
right side of that conflict
um and uh it was it was the honor of my
lifetime to to serve at the Utah skater
Bruiser and be a part of them
yeah
we
were not the first and we won't be the
last
and there's people that are listening
this right now they're going to be in
those leadership positions
there's there's people that are you you
might be listening this right now it
might be in three years it might be in
three months it might be in 10 years I
didn't shoot my weapon at the end of the
enemy for 13 years
for 13 years
but just know just listen to what we're
saying look we try and teach our our
Leadership Lessons all the time cover
Move simple prioritize and execute
decentralized command we literally
started a company to to pass these
lessons on
but
if you are not thinking about these
truly impactful lessons
that we were
that we got to live through
we got to live through it and and and
you know I said that before about combat
you go you go through combat you don't
wish it on anybody but you're I'm as you
said it was an honor that we actually
got to do what we did
and the lessons that we learned we try
and teach but this is like another area
and and you know sometimes I think it
seems
obvious
you know it's some it seems obvious now
but I also know and as a matter of fact
you and I were talking about this
yesterday
there's a lot of pressure on a young
leader there is a ton of pressure on a
young leader
all kinds of pressures you want to be
liked you want to get the job done you
don't want to let your guys down you
want your guys to respect you you want
to do the right thing but at the same
time sometimes the right thing is viewed
as different by different people all
those things all those things are going
on
all those things are going on
let me tell you this there's no escaping
this
there's no escaping this you have to own
what happens in your team you have to
you have ownership of that there's no
getting out of it there's no sloughing
it off on anybody else you can't do it
when you when something happens it's
yours you own it
when your sniper takes a shot you might
as well uphold the trigger
when your machine gunner lays down fire
you might as well be the person laying
down fire it's on you it's on you
and if you have that attitude you might
recognize that hey I gotta get control
of this situation
and if you think you can cover things up
you can't it's always going to come out
so if you're in a leadership position do
me and life a favor and Lead
it's not easy
it's not easy especially not lazy right
in that moment that's when it's most
important
with that
uh appreciate everybody listening what
do you got Echo give us a freaking uh
what do we used to call that rough
transition no no give us a rough
transition man we're not transitioning
out yet okay I got some questions
uh so you mentioned rewind a little
vegan are you gonna ask life if if you
have to be in the Navy to be a seal
like if you haven't heard this yet at
the end of the podcast that question uh
at the end of the podcast with Admiral
mcraven
Echo Charles who
is a grown man he's been he's been on
this podcast with me for seven years he
sat and listened to hundreds of military
books and Military guests
am I built up enough he asked Admiral
mcraven uh do you have to be in the Navy
to be an admiral
well anyways what do you got for us
today I guess I mean technically he
could be a coast guard Apple because
actually he said that right he did say
that he was like well I guess in the
Coast Guard or something like that what
a pro he was a pro I
[Music]
I thought you were leading up to a joke
I thought this was going to go somewhere
he's like do you have to be in the Navy
to be an admiral well and you I could
see like he
Admiral flashes eyes me for like a
millisecond like is this real and I was
just like oh no it is
I went into it so go ahead I'm gonna
give a reception of that because uh
remember we had uh
we had an individual
um and uh in our in our task here that
we we called
Captain Obvious oh and he wasn't he got
promoted he got promoted to Admiral
obvious and then and then that didn't
sound cool enough so we had to go to
field Marshall obviously so I guess you
could definitely be Admiral obvious and
not be in the Navy all right well what
do you got clarification from that thank
you Taco for that run down but no
clarification was I said how do I become
Admiral so I equally dumb questions
on the outside because it's like hey
remember we just discuss it afterwards
like what's like the process yeah you
know like Sheriff you kind of got to run
for Sheriff right yeah okay or like
Governor is different than just getting
promoted to God anyway I didn't know
that process I'm sorry oh yes that's
true and then through that asking
process I said what do I have to I have
to be in the Navy you know like almost
like confirming it because I figured but
I I don't know but maybe you could be in
the Coast Guard or Marines I don't know
I didn't know for sure you're gonna be a
general well what's your question for
today all right rewind back to the
trophies taking trophies four trophies
yeah damn you've been thinking about
that for the last three hours a little
bit because it kind of makes sense what
you're saying makes sense but so why do
you think
that they're like hey that's not
that's not permitted at all because
technically I'll tell you what God I
figure anyway I don't know maybe this is
the answer where it feels like it could
be a slippery slope almost like a you
know like your thing with the drinking
and the big boy rules and all that stuff
right where it's like big brother rules
right you'd think you know in a nutshell
it's like okay big bird rules everyone's
responsible here no problems but inch by
inch probably problems can come about
and then if you take that to like
an extent like um an extreme you get
just people drinking all the time yep
kind of the same deal yep
um I I think you're right I think it's
just a the easiest blank the easiest way
to lead this is say no war trophies
it doesn't make it the right thing to do
but yeah I could see the slippery slope
being like oh we're gonna have guys here
trying to smuggle back yeah what they
should have said is like hey here's a
protocol yeah you know every every you
know company-sized element is allowed to
take back three uh enemy weapons they
have to go through this process you know
and I kind of said like it'd be cool to
have one on my wall which it would be
yeah but at a minimum to say like a
company-sized element is allowed to take
some War trophies for their freaking
Heritage you know like at Seal Team
three right now there should be a wall
that has
some RP some Iraqi Insurgent RPGs they
they did do that in Vietnam like there's
seals that brought stuff home from
Vietnam I think the statute of
limitations probably clear by now but
you know that you can go and you can see
like they have some of that stuff they'd
have in some of their sometimes we'd
have old like chi-comps in the weapons
in the Armory so they would bring stuff
home
Moki Martin and other uh Vietnam air
seals would would we had that despite on
the old Seal Team one quarterback with
the b40 rocket that had been shot at
them and uh some AK-47s and things like
that you know uh just weapons that
they'd recovered so there's a there's a
real Heritage uh thing to it I think the
the bummer about this is that for really
senior people they were able to make
that happen you know so they're they're
like hey I'm gonna put that in my office
I've got this so like they pulled
strings uh I know there's some there's
some senior people out there that have
that stuff in their office but I think
for the front line Troopers that were
like hey man it'd be really cool to have
this you know
that we we captured on target from this
particular bad guy you know D milled
them like put up put on the wall yeah
um and we weren't allowed to do that it
was like no war trophies yeah uh
whatsoever it was like evil and bad and
yet then you like walk into a command
and you're like oh where did that come
oh that 2005 like Baghdad okay
we we we messed that up so yeah War
trophies next time you know
think about that their leaders give give
the opportunity to get some get some put
some protocols in place here's your War
trophy you ever seen the movie Three
Kings
no I haven't seen it but I know what
it's about they find gold right in Iraq
yeah I mean there's yeah there's kind of
more to it so
if and we won't go into the movie I know
you're thankful but it's like one of
those things where hey you know we go on
these missions and maybe there's like
some down time and remember oh I
remembered that one guy he might have
and it's hypothetical obviously
um that one guy he had a bunch of I
don't know cool weapons we caught him no
one grabbed the weapons let's go back
and get those weapons for our war trophy
kind of a thing like a it's almost like
you can kind of Imagine a scenario like
that where where you know people might
take it upon themselves to maybe or skew
their priorities of their presence there
in favor of words so there's words about
that the other reason for the rule yeah
right right and that's kind of what the
three kings movie was about essentially
it could it could that's another reason
maybe there's some you know thing I'm
not thinking about but for me
um because technically think about any
rule where it's like wait a sec there's
no rule against this bruh that thing can
lose control really that's why you put a
pro accomplice yeah you know yeah
to your point Echo there's always some
jackass that does you know uh if you
allow something like that somebody goes
and loots or does something stupid and
you know the one person does something
bad and prevents other people
um you know but I mean to me I look at
it as like hey if your grandfather took
a Luger off a German officer and you
know and Bastone and you know World War
II that's a pretty freaking cool family
heirloom you know to have around like
that's something to that thing is or or
a flag you know I mean it's not just
weapons but it's uh there's there's some
neat things like that that I think are
worth having that preserve history yeah
and this when you start talking about
the slippery slope just going back to
this whole conversation we just had
about ethics and what you're going to do
and what you're not going to do and and
literally taking care of the boys right
taking care of the boys look
if
JP DaNell is 23 years old and he gets in
a fight out in town
guess what I'm gonna do what I can to
make sure that he doesn't get in any
trouble at all and and I'm gonna take
care of him now is he gonna maybe get
some freaking
get an ass chewing is he absolutely is
he gonna get some extra duty is he
absolutely is he gonna be the designated
driver on the next three trips that we
go on absolutely so there's this I don't
wanna I don't wanna number one I don't
want to give the impression because it's
not the right impression that I was like
oh you know if you crossed if you do
disobey any rule at any time I'm gonna
you know you're out that's that's not
what we're talking about I probably
should have clarified that better like
hey you're gonna you're a young team guy
you're gonna do some dumb stuff you're
young whatever Marine you're gonna do
some dumb stuff
I'm not gonna wreck your career over it
right so there is there is that and and
I
I'm actually probably kind of known for
that like if you hey look man you do
something dumb out in town or you make a
mistake or you even you know going
through the house you do something
stupid it's like oh I'm gonna ruin your
career no actually I'm gonna train you
going back to what I said earlier if JP
DaNell gets in a fight out in town whose
fault is it this is actually my fault I
actually didn't do a good job explaining
how if JP can't go on deployment with us
he's aiding Al Qaeda do you think JP
Danelle wants to hear the words you're
aiding Al-Qaeda the freaking guy would
go nuts
so so it's actually my fault but if I
didn't do a good job of making him
understand that and then he ends up
getting in trouble well I failed him I'm
not going to fail him twice I'm gonna
say dude all right listen you just got
your freaking you just got your uh your
alcohol drinking card pulled you're not
allowed to drink anymore until you know
until we get back from deployment
you are the designated driver from now
on you are gonna do whatever whatever
little assignments to get them tightened
up and make sure he doesn't get in
trouble again
so that's how you take care of the boys
and then it goes into hey there's things
that you could do that are immoral
illegal unethical and if you cross those
lines
you're on your own and I'm actually
gonna do my best to crush you because I
don't want you to misrepresent the teams
the nation our country
so just I wanted to get that point of
clarification because I don't want a
bunch of my uh guys that work for me
over the years sitting there going what
are you talking about because yes if you
did something stupid I was gonna handle
it I was no I was I just had a couple
conversations over the past weekend you
know we had some retirement ceremonies
and whatnot and I had some great
conversations with guys that were like
oh
hey remember when you when I did this
and you
you this is what you did to me and
basically what I did to them was punish
them on by myself not running up the
chain of command and I had I for some
reason this this is this is an
interesting statement
I didn't mind if someone did something
dumb
I didn't mind being the senior guy with
a secret like the senior guy like okay
this happened you did something stupid
it stops with me you're gonna get
punished and by the way if the my boss
calls and says what the hell I just
found out about this you know what I say
oh yeah sir I didn't want to bother with
you here's the punishment that I
administered here's you know he's no
longer allowed to drink he's the
designated driver for the next six
months like all those things that's what
I did I'm okay with that and my boss
still might get mad but my boss probably
is gonna say all right Roger that I got
it next time you better give me a heads
up in case this comes back
so being the senior man with a secret on
something that you have
you have handled
and something that's not like a stain on
the reputation of the teams or uh or a
transgression of the morals of a human
I got you
you do some dumb [__] like you know we
we were I did a whole freaking vid we
did a whole podcast about doing dumb
[__] yeah
and if you do some dumb [__] you work
for me and you're a good dude I'm Gonna
Make sure you do less of it
uh you know life you did some dumb [__]
right guess what plenty of dumb [__] do
you do plenty of dumb [__] did I
freaking write you up and and and uh
give you a bad fit rep no because you
just did some dumb [__] we're gonna
learn from it no big deal
Stoner I think Stoner wasn't out doing
dumb [__] come on this dude was a
captain dumb [__] right he's getting out
out there getting after it what are we
doing like hey bro
you can't do that here what what think
about the repercussions
think about what you know like we think
through these things
so again I don't I don't want to sit
here and give this impression that we're
over here running running the Boy Scouts
right we're over here running the Boy
Scouts because we're not we're not
running the Boy Scouts
the Boy Scouts doesn't have to kill
people for a living we do but the the
people that are going to kill people for
11 they got a lot of testosterone in
their body you know how testosterone
affects people you know makes people
want to fight
makes people want to go get with girls
this is what happens this is not like
this is the physiological stuff that
goes down so what kind of person wants
to become a frog man
I'll tell you what kind of person he
wants to become a frogman he's got a
high testosterone level he wants to
fight he wants to break [__] that's what
he wants to do I actually want that guy
in my platoon
and it's my responsibility to make sure
he knows what to break and who to fight
and who to kill that's my responsibility
to take that frog man and keep him
contained and make sure he doesn't get
in trouble that's on me
so I just wanted to clarify that point
couldn't make sense so maybe back to the
trophies thing maybe all
your forefathers World War II Vietnam
they took trophies right it wasn't a
rule whatever and then after a while
maybe it kind of started to get out of
hand then someone was like hey no
trophies see I'm saying maybe they could
do it and that's why the rule was made
there we go I got mine
something like that I don't know hey
yeah no and you can see where all of a
sudden it turns into you know every
single person's got their War trophy
which honestly I'm still good with that
like I think it should be like hey if
you deploy and you're in combat arms you
get your you can get you can bring back
one you know weapon
and you know what I bet you're right too
like I've heard some of those stories
about
like the Marines going on the beach and
they come back out and the Navy guys
would do anything to get you know a
Japanese freaking samurai sword or
whatever a German Luger you know then
maybe you get into black market stuff
like maybe it just escalates to the
point where they just had to shut it
down but again you need to make a
protocol if you make a protocol like
you're allowed to take one you're
allowed one weapon it needs to be
demilled it needs to be serialized it
needs to be assigned to you and you're
gonna sign for it yeah Eugene Sledge
you've ever talked about that with and
with the old breed where he's like
making fun of the guys that that were
coming in like the you know after they
did all the fighting and Okinawa or uh
and and pelaloo and then and then like
oh now you got these these guys that are
showing up in like clean uniforms that
are looking for like a uh you know some
souvenir to take home uh they obviously
weren't collecting souvenirs because
they were busy fighting the Japanese so
I think there's those that those things
can be controlled right we're not
talking about just uncontrolled looting
and pillaging we're talking about fall
going up carefully you know crafting
Rules of Engagement when you're when
you're talking about captured weapons
that were enemy property that they've
now forfeited and we had a giant Armory
full of them that at 10 uh to Bruiser we
were in ramadi we should have brought
them all home yeah it would have emailed
them all that would have been so awesome
they can't work anymore okay yeah it's
just something to put up on the wall so
you don't have to worry about it it's
not a working weapon right
yeah it's it's uh it would it would have
been super cool though to have that
stuff yeah that's so sometimes I'm a
little bit too much of a rule follower
you know that's one of those situations
that it's like hey you know like here's
a situation where I didn't follow the
rules was they were hot on the
photograph thing like you're not allowed
to take pictures of operations and
I have my first deployment we didn't we
we followed the rule like I was like hey
here's the rule and so no pictures it
was so it was very limited pictures I
don't have a lot of pictures from that
first deployment
um
again there was some situations where
guys took pictures I'm actually and I'm
actually thankful but uh probably a
little while into our deployment I kind
of realized we better take pictures of
our friends and uh I'm really thankful
that we did that because
we now have pictures of our friends that
aren't here anymore you know and that's
freaking awesome
but that was a rule and it was actually
a heavily enforced rule at the time
because photographs were against general
order number one like you weren't
allowed to take pictures
you know uh it actually wasn't general
order number one general order number
one said you couldn't take pictures of
like enemy combatants but the NS the
naval special Warfare rule at the time
was like no pictures of operations
period that's it period and and so
we weren't and then very quickly in
deployment I cleared everyone I was like
hey take freaking pictures because we're
we're gonna want them
um
and that's one of those rules you know
gotta and I would I could easily uh
explain that to anyone in my chain of
command that would have said hey why did
you take pictures I said hey we were in
a serious combat situation there was a
chance someone was going to get killed
and I wanted it us to have pictures of
our freaking friends and if you want to
send me to uh Court martial for that
let's go
let's go because I think that's I think
is actually the ethical and moral and
right thing to do was to take pictures
and we did so there's an example you
know
um we didn't quite follow the rule
oh well all right
um let's wrap this up you got any more
questions Echo Charles no no that was
that was it thanks awesome hey uh if you
want to support this podcast go to
jocofuel.com get yourself some some go
drinks they're awesome I'm too deep
right now too deep into the Jocko fuels
you only got down one I got one one
Citrus cycle I gotta get on it yeah uh
check you can get those you can get the
the Mulk
the ready to drink milk the pow-pow milk
yep Bros on a call
last night even look at this guy with
with the one Dave Burke good deal Dave
good deal dude so he he actually brought
up a good or not a good question
necessarily but he brought up a question
that got me thinking hey wait we don't
talk about like all the stuff that Jocko
fuel actually has I'm not gonna do it
right now necessarily but yeah floating
yeah but
[Music]
you can see all this stuff because it's
not just we always blow up the drinks
and then you know the energy drinks and
the RTD because that's like super
exciting right now you know but there's
like all kinds there's like joint stuff
tent like test stuff sleep stuff there's
a lot of cool stuff on there that we
might be
um doing a disservice in a small way of
not mentioning for certain people well
check this out go to jockoffuel.com and
you can check out all the stuff you can
check out the joint Warfare the super
girl the time war time War all day the
time where all day the I mean oh it's
not all day it's everyday it's just a
good way to feel better across the board
in a in a legitimate way so give that
one a crack oh you can get the stuff at
Vitamin Shoppe you can get it at Wawa
while you're gonna have to look
a little bit trying to get we're getting
squeeze we're getting the squeeze from
some of the big
Empire beverage companies
so but Vitamin Shop number one brand did
you know that no big deal yeah we're in
the military comments conversation we're
working on the military exchanges too
God it pisses me off when I go into the
the NEX and we don't we're not in there
I like going to the commissary and we're
in there that's good but the NEX and all
they have is poison for our troops
for our troops
for these men and women that are putting
their lives on the line and they gotta
then we're feet we're we're actively
giving them stuff that's bad for them
well this is wrong
so we're working on it Hannaford's Dash
stores wake Fern shop or ShopRite
HEB Tejas
you gave me a report this morning from
the field life Babin yeah representing
my local heb's got a got uh awesome like
end cap of Mulk and uh this one go
that's outstanding it's awesome yeah so
grow into HEB rolling the Meijer out in
the midwest lifetime fit you know what
Lifetime Fitness is yes dude have you
been to a Lifetime Fitness yeah they're
insane have you been to a Lifetime
Fitness I am freaking massive massive
gym anyways they're they're good to go
they're working it
um
yeah so go check all that out get
yourself some Jocko fuel jockoffuel.com
it's true also origin
USA so you go to originusa.com this is
where we're getting our jeans you know
there's a new black wash jeans yeah
they're black yeah
you know what you know uh I I am gonna I
think I think those black jeans
especially when they're new are going to
be suitable for like a little bit
elevated scenarios yes you know what I'm
saying yes like date night yeah yeah and
I know hey look I know you're not into
the fashion uh rules I don't know maybe
life is I don't know maybe maybe not
questionably he's doing good right now
but either way so the the the darker the
gene the more formal yeah oh yeah you
look good too by the way the more form
of the scenario the more formal the
scenario yes the more special the snare
so like daytime scenario like a daytime
um event or whatever so it's more casual
that's going to be the lighter jeans bro
I walk down
like with a pair of jeans on and then
teach a black T-shirt down from where
down from my like house Upstairs
Downstairs walk downstairs and my
daughter my 13 year old daughter sees me
with like jeans and a black T-shirt on
and she goes hey oh she's like oh why
are you all dressed up and the dark
jeans no no these are just jeans oh okay
yeah
that's pretty awesome yeah you know I
love most about the origin jeans is they
got that little stretch to them and uh
and our Jam store Jiu Jitsu we have uh
combatives uh program so we're watching
we train with like weapons uh
um you know weapon shapes and stuff and
so they're they're awesome to roll in
they're like it's it's plain clothes so
you got to have your oh you have your
shirt Locker shirt on and your uh your
origin jeans stoic Jiu Jitsu yeah
what's the address what's the scenario
where are we at we're in Dripping
Springs Texas Dripping Springs Tejas
Marcus douthit awesome uh instruction
and it's uh yeah every every Friday we
run a combatives program for some uh
some of the Sheepdog response
instructors that train there
um Tim Kennedy's program yeah it's
awesome it's uh the combatants program
is is legit and those origin genes are
everybody in there straight into origin
what's good about that is um you know
just the same way that I talk about Jiu
Jitsu like if somebody if if you don't
train and someone grabs you you have a
level of
panic and shock and and unknown to
overcome before you can even take action
like you're just Frozen for at least
even if you're even if you're a squared
away person you don't know what to do
for at least three quarters of a second
and by the way that could be all it
takes so when you start doing combatives
when you start training like you start
training pistol you start training
knives you start thinking through those
things
you all of a sudden you're okay and that
three quarters of a second it starts to
get minimized I'd actually have to run
the numbers let's see if you don't if
you don't train Jiu Jitsu and someone
grabs you you're probably dealing with
10 seconds others five seconds six
seconds before you start processing
what's happening in a legitimate way
if you change Jiu Jitsu you're you
didn't there's zero seconds you're
already processing it's the same thing
with like doing combatives doing weapons
type training where someone's pulling a
knife on you if you've never seen it
before you are not not knowing what to
do for five seconds even literally even
if the reaction is I know I need to run
away
if you haven't fought through that
before that knife comes out and you
freeze for three seconds guess what you
just got stuck in the neck you're
bleeding out homie
so so don't let that happen yeah so
actually when you were setting up uh
your gym stoic Jiu Jitsu you sent me the
name you're like we're gonna be called
stoic Jiu Jitsu I just I stoically just
nodded to myself I thought hell yeah
hell yeah especially because Mark's kind
of stoic dude right marks the total stew
again so Stoke Juju check it out
Dripping Springs
uh how many times a week do you have
classes how many times a day do you have
classes uh three three Class A Day for
adult classes a couple kids classes the
Utes um yeah three Monday through
Thursday as well so it's uh it's a great
program uh awesome training down there
and um yeah that that that just quality
instruction do you have a website um
yeah so jiu jitsu.com
got it go get in there people go get in
there
stokejitsu.com freaking good name it's a
good one man you done good uh you figure
those Delta 68 genes
are gonna be kind of different and maybe
even better in a way than even gee pants
when you think about it because as far
as the mobility goes you're saying yeah
they're more mobile than he pants they
are they are mobile they are more mobile
we actually are have some experimental
phase ghee pants right now now there's
gonna be problems right because you got
you got ibjf you got rules you're not
allowed to have stretch because it's
going to interfere with things but we're
trying to see what is the what is the
parameters of that like what what what
could be legal right because there's a
certain amount of stretch that gives no
difference as far as Jiu Jitsu goes but
giving you a little bit more of that
Mobility yeah now listen as a as a as a
Jocko right now
I'm definitely not getting limited by my
Jiu Jitsu pants I'm getting limited by
my own freaking lack of ability to
stretch a little bit my lack of lack of
mobility in my own self
I was gonna say like right as I was
saying that I can just hear Pete right
now yelling at me like of all the like
different things they've done to design
the ghee pads to be so mobile I have a
pair that's got I have a pair that's got
a little just a little bit like he sent
me the experimental once for real and
here's the thing I think if you didn't
announce that they were stretched no one
would be able to tell yeah so I think
that's probably going to be the answer
like it's so small you can feel it but
you can't feel it right you can feel it
but they can't feel it is what I'm
getting at yeah and that's how it would
have to be because the stretchiness I
mean obviously there's different ways
you can have somebody grabbing your ghee
pants yeah it kind of defeats a lot of
the purpose of the the ghee to begin
with right so but
the mobility or lack of Mobility has
never been an issue in ghee pants I
don't think especially the origin ones
I'm just saying stretch wise because
look we're putting on jeans we're
putting on jeans for a different reason
than we put in on the ghee pants let's
face it apparently I have some kind of a
black tie event I'm going to so I'm
putting on jeans it's all day yeah hell
yeah
um so I get it it's not the keypads are
not mobile it's just that as far as
stretch goes you're going for looks
formal or informal depending on who you
are you put the jeans on you're gonna
have some Mobility uh in the event of
you having to do Jiu Jitsu or combatives
that's the case maybe
origin USA get yourself some of this
stuff by the way it's made in America uh
everything we just talked about
going and fighting and trying to
preserve freedom in the world
that's awesome we appreciate the
military 100 for sure we also have to
appreciate economic power
and right now we've shifted economic
power overseas that's what we've done
we've done it the corporations have done
it they've just voluntarily said oh we
can make an extra
dollar 78 cents on every pair of jeans
so we'll just fire everyone we have here
in America and we'll move the factories
overseas and that's exactly what they
did
because they're scum
their scum well we're not doing that
we're we're building here every when you
put on a pair of origin jeans or An
Origin ghee or An Origin rash guard you
are
putting on the cloth of the nation
actually this is American made from the
cotton to the rivets to the zipper It's
All American made so get yourself on
board with America get yourself into a
situation where you are defending
America and bringing back this economic
power that we've given away and by the
way it starts with manufacturing things
like jeans and clothing but we're
reliant on other countries
actually adversarial countries for
things that we need
and that's terrible for our national
security
so let's start you can start with a pair
of jeans you may not feel like you're
helping out our national security when
you buy a pair of jeans but you are
you're actually helping out our national
security when you buy a pair of jeans
that's what you're doing so look you may
or may not have served this country as a
military individual
if you did thank you
if you didn't
you can still serve
by by building our economy
so there you go originusa.com
also the shirt that Leif is wearing
from Jocko store this is where the
jocklestore.com is where you can
represent the path that we're all on
discipline equals Freedom good is the
case may be
all different uh
attire items on there the shirt Locker
man those are my favorite shirts they're
awesome you know shirt Locker if you
don't know is the subscription service
every month you get a new shirt let's
see you know sometimes there's a hit
sometimes there's a Smash Hit of the in
the shirt Locker design wise
as Leaf is demonstrating right now with
his current shirt anyway
yeah I think so so a lot of people like
that one what was the inspirato behind
that shirt okay so so it says if you're
just listening it says good but it says
in a fancy kind of cursive kind of way
kind of a black type kind of affair
calligraphy-ish right so it's kind of
yeah like a black tie right so so the
idea is the layers if you will oh that's
the thing all the designs have some sort
of a story kind of layers behind it the
one for this one is okay so you know
good right the whole thing it's like hey
when things go bad there's always some
good to come from it so when you said
that you were in saying it in reference
to the original Source material was when
Seth would be like hey you always say
that like you know real for real stuff
in life like military operation like
that kind of stuff
not all of us are in that kind of those
kind of deep waters you know where we
gotta reference the good terminology
right not all of a sudden that some some
of us are kind of more on a for lack
better term a higher level
more um how should I say everyday kind
of level it's not it's not down in the
dirt it's kind of higher up on this on
the maybe the street maybe even the
third fourth fifth floor level we're
talking for is this the first world good
over here yes that is exactly exactly
what that shirt is think about it look
at it it's like so it's called good high
level problems so like hey look high
level problems meaning not load down in
the dirt so it's high level meaning hey
meaning yeah I'm trying to potty train
my dog and it freaking went in my off
home office right I'm saying like that
kind of stuff meaning my Mercedes has a
flat tire or whatever yeah or what have
you you know my Cadillac Escalade for
the echo Charles it shouldn't be called
high levels problems it should be called
good everyday problems I think it should
be called first world problems first
world problems yeah I think so too yeah
which is with the funny thing about that
is you legitimately have to say if you
got a flat tire on your Cadillac
Escalade Echo Charles yeah you can
legitimately be like good you know I got
a Cadillac Escalade bro that's a lot
that's true I get to practice my tire
changing uh capabilities
that's right so there you go Jocko store
uh subscribe to this podcast uh Jocko
underground subscribe to that too
cost eight dollars and 18 cents a month
unless you can't afford it then you just
email
for the email assistance.com
subscribe to the YouTube channels we got
we got for YouTube channels we got Jocko
podcast we got origin USA we got Jaco
food we got Ashley on front we got
Ashley on front uh YouTube channel
yes we do some some content on there so
go and check those out subscribe to them
we got psychological warfare we got
Flipside canvas Dakota Meyer
Dakota Meyer just freaking stud and he's
got studly stuff for you to hang on your
wall
so go check out flipsidecamvas.com and
go get something to hang on your wall we
got a bunch of books
um that we've written uh check those out
final spin leadership strategy tactics
code district freedom field manual the
way the warrior kids series there's five
I keep meeting people I'm doing this I'm
such a bad Advertiser
I have people go oh yeah I read your
Warrior Kid book the first one yeah
they're like it's the best book ever
I've had people say you should write
more I'm like there's four more kid kid
in the game where's your parents I'm
gonna smack them around it's their fault
uh yeah no it's my fault as I just said
because I haven't done a good job of of
putting the word out so get those books
for you for all those kids miking the
dragons about face extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership
written by myself
and Leif bab and Senator you heard a lot
from him today so yeah we wrote those
books so a while back
we also have a leadership consultancy
which is called Echelon front and we
solve problems through leadership we've
worked with
every different kind of company that you
can imagine in every different industry
We Take Lessons Learned From combat from
the battlefield
from life and we help you solve problems
through leadership
you can go to echelonfront.com for
details I know you're heading out you're
heading out after this going to work
with a construction company and good
deal Dave yep and that's what that's
what we do so let's say a construction
company in this instance they're wanting
to perform better they're wanting to do
better oh what do they want to do better
at doesn't really matter they want to do
better as a construction company they
have some issues
okay cool how do we solve those issues
we solve those issues through leadership
that's what we do at Echelon front so go
to estelonfront.com if you need help
inside your organization and we'll get a
team out to you to assess and then fix
that's what we're doing we also have
some Live Events
I guess the next the next muster is
Dallas October 18th through the 20th
and we we oversold the last monster so
we sell out and then we sell out a
little bit more so we we sold out it was
cry it was it wasn't like overly crowded
where you were stuffed in there but the
none of the instructor staff or
excellent front staff got a seat we had
to give it all up to people so my point
is we sell out so you should uh if you
want to go to one of those things you
want to go to go to Gettysburg you want
to go to the Battle of Little Bighorn
you need to go and register now you want
to go to the FTX and see what it's like
to utilize these things in simulated
combat situations so that they really
make sense and then you can apply them
in your life go to the FTX so we got all
those things
go to ashlandfront.com
we also have an online training academy
where you can learn to take ownership of
your life
that's what that's what you can do there
and man it is
magic it's magic in the same way that
Jiu Jitsu is Magic yes it's magic in the
same way that Jiu Jitsu is magic so back
in the day
back in the day if you knew jiu jitsu
you could win any fight right you could
you could oh this person's gonna mess
with me cool I'll beat him hoist Gracie
UFC one goes up against boxers and
wrestlers and Muay Thai and just is able
to beat him why because he understood
this magic called jiu jitsu
there's magic to leadership and by the
way just what leadership means is
interacting with other human beings
that's what it means
that's that's actually what leadership
is you're going to communicate to those
human beings you're going to build
relationships with those human beings
and it doesn't matter if they're in your
wife or your husband it doesn't matter
if they're your co-workers at work it
doesn't matter if it's your children's
football team
it doesn't matter if it's your buddy
your girlfriend you have to interact
with other human beings that's what's
going on
and there's actual moves
there's actual magic just like jiu jitsu
and if you want to learn some of that
magic you want to learn what to do when
someone's irate with you you want to
learn what to do when someone is blaming
you you want to learn what to do when
one of your subordinates is not
completing their projects on time you
want to know what to do when your boss
is not making any decisions
you want to know what to do when your
husband
is leading the family in the wrong
direction you want to get it steered in
another Direction well
that's what we teach this little bit of
magic it's just like Jiu Jitsu you can
get it all under control go to extreme
ownership.com we've got a bunch of
courses on there we do live sessions
what's the latest course do you know
what the latest course to get posted is
relationships but gee
gee oh I mean I don't know how to work a
relationship cool just like idiots used
to say I know how to fight you don't
know how to fight you don't
you don't know how to fight
you don't know how to build
relationships there's actual tactics
techniques and procedures that you can
utilize to build relationships
those are the facts you don't know what
they are you think you know what they
are but you don't just like just like I
was in 1992 thought I knew how to fight
as soon as I got on the mats of Justice
I learned there's techniques there's
tactics there's procedures there's
Maneuvers I don't know
so it's the same thing with leadership
go to extreme ownership.com learn how to
lead
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families their gold star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee
she's got an incredible charity
organization if you want to donate you
want to get involved go to America's
Mighty Warriors dot org also check out
heroesandhorses.org that's where Micah
Fink is taking
veterans out into the Wilderness where
they are finding themselves
it's really helping out a lot of
individuals so check that out
what else we got if you want to connect
with us
Leif where are you at on the winterwebs
where are you at what's your social
media uh real life Batman on Instagram
and Leif Babin on uh Facebook and
Twitter and Linkedin there you go Echoes
on there
it's true he's at Echo Charles I'm at
Jocko willink just watch out when you
sign into those things they're tracking
you they're trying to get into your
brain they got that algorithm
algorithms coming after you and it's
it's strong has no rules of engagement
by the way it doesn't care doesn't care
about collateral damage doesn't care
that you are gonna miss Jiu Jitsu
because you are watching something
stupid it doesn't care about that
doesn't care but that you're not paying
attention to your kid because you're
scrolling through your timeline
they should call it the time sucker
right the Time Eater the time Destroyer
not a timeline no
no his timeline is timeline on Facebook
or his timeline on Instagram or Twitter
one is timeline one is news feed oh yeah
and then it should be called the brain
Eater Not the news feeder because it's
killing you but we are on there so there
you go uh Lathan thanks for coming back
appreciate it was good damn we just
talked for a long time didn't we yes we
did but at least we hit record at the
appropriate time uh and hey thank you to
all of our military men and women that
are out there right now
doing the right things for the right
reasons holding the line and protecting
this great nation while defending the
moral High Ground
thanks to all of you also thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders thanks for what you
do
keep us safe
and everyone else out there
you gotta take The High Ground
and you got to keep The High Ground the
Tactical High Ground on the battlefield
and you more importantly
have to maintain that moral High Ground
and you do that
by taking ownership
[Music]
taking ownership preemptive ownership
knowing that there are no excuses
and you cannot recover
you have to take the moral High ground
and you have to keep it and you do that
by doing the right thing
doing the legal thing
and until next time
this is Leif and Echo and Jocko
out